hi this is an ALT shift X live stream
we're going to talk about House of the
Dragon episode 8 we're going to answer
your questions and we are not going to
spoil future episodes
and we're gonna have a good time and my
God what what an episode this was we've
had another time skip so our characters
the kids have been aged up again and
some of the kids have had their own kids
I don't know well I don't think they
actually mentioned aegon and Helena's
children yet but they're around and
Daemon and rhaenyra have had kids
called aegon and viserys
which does make things confusing because
we already have an aegon as the child of
viserys and Allison
and we also had Jace and Luke recast as
older versions of themselves Baylor and
Rayna as well
and we see that um
in King viserys's
last days
all the adults are Keen to make peace
and to prevent conflict they decide that
now at the very last minute is a great
time to start making peace and all
getting along again
um but alas the children are not so
forgiving I thought that was really
wonderful the way that happened because
they had this wonderful awkward
Thanksgiving dinner with Alice inside of
the family and rhaenyra's side of the
family all together with viserys trying
to finally make peace among his people
and while the adults while Alison and
Rainier were genuinely trying to make a
go of of getting along
it was their children who were not it
was their children who continued the
generational conflict that they learned
from their parents so just after
everything was kind of going okay and
everyone was getting along amond
Targaryen gives his shitstering speech
insulting Jason Luke and calling them
strongs and the fight starts Anew the
fight that the adults trained them for
you know just like with the fight in the
previous episode These adults have been
treating these kids
Allison's kids and rhaenyra's kids as
though they are enemies teaching them to
fight teaching them that Varsity is this
shameful secret that you can use to hurt
each other so of course they keep on
fighting so you know despite the adults
attempts to make some peace in this
episode The inertia of their of their
conflict continues
um and now and now the king is dead ring
the bells the king is dead viserys died
and uh thanks for the donation from
Ludacris who says that um
who says that it's weird that prophecy
motivating Allison is a strange decision
I think there's a few ways to interpret
what what happened here because in
viserys's last moments he was speaking
to Allison and viserys thought that he
was speaking to rhaenyra continuing
their earlier conversation about aegon's
prophecy
and so viscerra says that like oh the uh
the prince that was promised and aegon
and and and the the dream about the
white walkers and everything
viserys is talking about aegon's
prophecy and he's talking about aegon
the Conqueror the guy who conquered
Westeros 30 years ago whereas Allison
the way she interprets viserys's words
uh she thinks that viserys is talking
about her son aegon
Prince aegon she says
and like I I don't think that's a very
reasonable interpretation of what the
series is saying right
um I think Alison chooses to believe
that viserys is talking about her son
being the rightful heir to the throne
um I think Alice that's that's on Alison
not on
um viserys but viserys was full of drugs
so um full of milk of the poppy so you
know I think this is on Allison if she
chooses to interpret viserys's words as
being about her son aegon I I don't
think Allison is going like oh White
Walkers like Alison is not really
interpreting this as a prophecy thing
I think that she's interpreting this as
a viserys wants my son to be king thing
which is not at all what he meant
uh we also had
um dramatically come to her head with
vemond trying to get himself to be the
next Lord of driftmark instead of lucery
near his son and uh and the King
unexpectedly turned up and laid down the
law one last time in support of his
grandson Luke
and then Daemon cut off vemon's head
which was which was wonderful and I was
not expecting
thanks for the Super Chat from Giro who
says they were so close to avoiding the
dance of the Dragons only to be set back
on the path by viserys being senile and
high yeah yeah the thing that I kept
thinking was viserys in this moment
should have legitimized Luke and Jace
because that's a thing that that Kings
can do like if someone is a bastard so
they don't have the right of inheritance
and whatever a king can say I legitimize
you I make you no longer a bastard you
are now a true born Heir like I mean
Roose Bolton with with King Joffrey's
permission did that with Ramsay Snow
making him into Ramsay Bolton and aegon
IV Targaryen made his bastard children
legitimized viserys should have done the
same with Jace and Luke by reckon he
should have said okay fine like they are
bastards but I legitimize them therefore
their inheritance is unquestionable I
mean the issue there is that if vasera
is legitimized Luke who Luke would have
no claim to drift Mark if you know
viserys admitted that Luke is actually
Harwin Strong's son not lane or
valerion's son but I don't know I feel
like this was an opportunity to make
things even more clear and viserys did
not quite go far enough because because
I mean that that's the issue is that
vemond Raymond is telling the truth all
vemond is saying here is that Luke and
Jace are bastards and they should not
inherit driftmark and I think weymon is
sympathetic in this moment because he
talks about how his house house for
larion is one of the last Valyrian
houses they have this ancient unique
history that is to some extent a raised
if Luke becomes the new Lord of
driftmark because he doesn't have a
Larry on blood and valerion blood does
have some Valyrian magic to it and if
the new Lord is does not have Valerie on
blood then that is like an end to that
bloodline so I think Vermont is
sympathetic in that extent although you
could also point out that well if Luke
marries Rayna Targaryen which is the
plan then his children will have some
true Valerian blood through Lena
valerion so
okay
we had some technical issues but it
should be better sorry about that
anyway
thanks for the Super Chat from Jacob and
from Wayne and from jarek who said that
vizzy made a WWE entrance I loved
viserys's entrance opening the doors
Midway through the speech walking in
slow even his costume with the mask and
everything like it's decrepit and creepy
but it's also kind of badass The Return
of the King I loved it I was real scared
that viserys was going to fall and like
cut himself on the throne because that's
something that um happens in the books
is that viserys like trips and falls and
slices his hand open on the Iron Throne
um
and I was terrified that that was gonna
happen but it was so beautiful and it
was so sweet when Daemon came and
supported his brother going up the
throne I thought that was a really
lovely show of affection and devotion
and support from a brother who has
otherwise been a bit of a pain in the
ass
um
so that was lovely and I wonder like you
know I think that viserys's death is
going to be
a huge deal to Daemon because you know
he has been so motivated by a desire for
Love from viserys like so much of his
whole
issue has been about you know not
feeling appreciated Enough by viserys
and now the viserys is dead it's like
you know where's Daemon gonna seek
affection from now I get you know I mean
Daemon is a family man now you know like
he's got he's got two kids with Rainier
he's got two kids with Lena
um
maybe that's where daemon's satisfaction
and identity comes from now I really
enjoyed like the uh sequence where
Daemon was like climbing around on
Dragonstone on the dragon mod which is
like the volcanic uh Mountain next to
the Dragonstone castle and he went and
found a new clutch of eggs laid by Cyrax
and I love I love the look of this
clutch of eggs because it's in this
weird sort of pod this sort of like hot
it looks like a bloody xenomorph egg I
was expecting a Facehugger to burst out
of this this weird pod that Daemon
pulled the eggs out of but we've never
seen this or had this described in the
books or the shows before but I really
enjoyed Daemon retrieving those eggs he
seems to have a passion for the dragon
eggs and of course you know that's a big
symbol for his children like daemon's
children with rhaenyra aegon and viserys
they will perhaps get those eggs if they
didn't already have eggs they might get
those eggs so they can have dragon of
their own thanks for the super chats
from Jacob and Elon green and Patrick
says where was Joffrey yeah so we did
get a brief look at Joffrey valerion who
is the child of Rainier and Harwin
supposedly Lena we saw him briefly
around
here
that that's him down there we saw a
brief look of Joffrey
um which is the first time we've seen
him since he was a little baby
but yeah we saw Joffrey and so Joffrey
is the brother of of Jason Luke yeah
there he is there's little Joffrey
lots of little kids running around now
thanks for the Super Chat from
Inquisitor who says is crab eater time
traveling busy like Tyrion is Danny's
time traveling fetus are you suggesting
that viserys is the crab feeder is that
what you're suggesting
so like they both wear they both wear
golden masks I can see the similarity
between viserys's mask and the crab
feeder's mask so what you're saying is
that when viserys died at the end of the
episode he actually traveled through
time and became the crab feeder pirate
and then viserys killed his own brother
that's an interesting Theory uh Jacob
asks do you think viserys saw Emma when
he died yeah I thought I thought
viserys's death was so beautiful and sad
and his last words his last words were I
think referring to Emma
um his last words are
my love and I think I think it's Emma
because like the writers and the actor
have talked about how viserys viserys is
very much motivated by love for his dead
wife Emma Aaron who is the mother of
Rainier and that rainy and that
viserys's support for uh Rainier is
largely an act of love and devotion and
guilt for his wife Emma who he still
feels guilty about the death of
um when he had to cut her open because
she had a baby inside her that was
killing her so that was a whole thing
and um yeah I thought that was really
lovely a wonderful performance by
viserys and real real horrifying seeing
the way they the way his body was
breaking down I thought that was done
quite effectively as well
uh thanks for the donation from Slevin
who says was it just me or did it look
like amond was intimidated by Daemon
when they stared at each other after
punches were thrown yeah I mean aemond
amond gets his power from being like
this you know tough scary no-nonsense
fighter but then he gets sort of stared
down by Daemon who is like the one
person in the room who is a you know
tougher scarier more dangerous more
chaotic dude
um so I think that's definitely a
rivalry we can keep our eyes on pun
intended I really enjoyed when they put
a pig down in front of amond I don't
know if that was like intentional or not
like do you think that Jace and Luke
like specifically told the waiter hey
aemond really likes pork could you maybe
put a pig in front of him because this
of course calls back to the pink dread
which was the pig that Luke and aegon
gave to amond episodes ago to tease him
um so you know we can see how how those
old all the old bullying and all the old
rivalries are still very much uh still
very fresh for these guys and of course
the eye I think is very much concerned
by uh the eye being lost so um so yeah
it was wonderful to see the pink dread
and aim on getting all pissy I thought
that uh it was really lovely to see
Helena as well we've seen Helena in a
couple of episodes previously she says
another weird
um cryptic thing again which I'm I don't
know what this one means what in the
chat what do you guys think it means
when Helena says beware the Beast
beneath the boards what does she mean by
that is she talking about something
beneath the floorboards beneath of the
boards of a bed is she talking about
like spies and little birds inside the
walls of the red keep under the floors
is she what what is I mean is she
talking about the sort of metaphorical
hatred
you guys are suggesting that it's um
yeah okay so we're not gonna we're not
We're not gonna give any spoilers but uh
yeah there is an incident later on that
uh she may be referring to
um so we'll see how that turns out uh I
like how they have kept sort of
reminding us throughout the season of
the various passages in the red cape
um but then after Helena said another
cryptic thing she actually said
something coherent for the first time
um she just gets up and talks about how
[ __ ] her husband is which I found very
funny uh because of course you know
aegon and Helena are married brother and
sister Targaryen incest but Helena just
gets up and gives a speech about how
well like you know married life isn't so
bad your husband mostly just ignores you
and has sex with other people except for
when he's drunk which kind of reminds me
of the Robert Baratheon Cersei Lannister
marriage which you know similarly Robert
mostly sort of ignored Cersei except for
when he was drunk
so it's a bit dark but it's also fun to
see Elena actually speak in like
coherent sentences for once like she
actually appears to know what's going on
in the world around her for once uh so
that's fun to see and Otto I thought
there was a lovely shot of Otto where
Otto looked uh rather proud of uh of
Helena Otto smiles and says good to
Helena after Helena gives a speech like
talking [ __ ] about her husband aegon
which gives me the sense that you know
Otto has been uh trying to get Helena to
I don't know act normal or whatever uh I
don't know I I enjoyed Elaine and Helena
did this wonderful dance with uh with
Jace which was fun
and aegon was um being an absolute uh
[ __ ] which was also entertaining so
you know I I think that these new actors
playing the kids are um are doing a good
job uh Robbie thanks for the Super Chat
says legitimizing the boys means
admitting that rhaenyra has been
committing treason by passing them off
as trueborn that crime can't be
uncommitted uh yeah so I was saying
before that you know maybe viserys
should legitimize Rainier as bastard
kids
um and yeah it would mean admitting that
Rainier like committed treason
um in having those bastards in the first
place but I mean I I think that for the
stability of the realm it's still on
balance might be better like like it's
all about the king like putting his
support behind those kids which I'm not
sure he did enough but yeah you do make
a fair point
um but again like you can you can
question like
there's also like the gendered aspect of
it like Rainier having bastards is seen
as a terrible crime when aegon having
bastards is not and all of aegon's
[ __ ] around like I really enjoyed the
scene where a serving girl
um was confronted by Alison because
aegon had sex with this serving girl
um she didn't want to so you know this
may have been a rape situation and so
Alison confronts her and she sort of she
she reminded me very much of Cersei
Lannister Alison's performance here
where she was like she was being uh she
was like looking after her and like
acting protective in one sense but she
was also threatening her by saying oh
you know what happens to girls who who
do what you did
um I worry about what others believe so
she was really like threatening and
manipulating this girl in a way that
reminded me of how Cersei threatened and
manipulated Sansa in Game of Thrones
um and I also got a sense of like
vindictiveness from elephant as though
Allison was sort of taking out her Spite
and frustration on
um this girl what was her name Diana
Diane
I got the sense that Alison was sort of
taking out some aggression on this girl
uh in the same way that Alison felt
spite against rhaenyra for her sexuality
I feel like Alison was sort of wielding
a similar tool against uh this poor girl
here and I thought it was a really great
performance by this girl as well she she
seemed so scared in a way that felt very
real I thought
um and you know it's also cool how
Allison is using the faith as her sort
of weapon in the inside the episode
the creators talked about Allison
turning to the faith as a sort of active
penitence after Allison's Outburst in
the previous episode when she cut
Rainier so Allison has sort of responded
by using religion to sort of reassure
herself and re-empower herself and um
replacing the Targaryen symbology with
faith of the seven symbology also has a
political element because house
Hightower is very close to the faith of
the seven and of course like you know
rhaenyra's sins of adultery and
rhaenyra's sins of having those bastards
um you know having the faith of the
seven is is a is a
um you know condemnation of rhaenyra's
actions as well so Lots going on there
um and you know the Faith's ties to
house Hightower and everything uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Jennifer who
says I think we learned a valuable
lesson this episode don't name everyone
freaking aegon yeah I really enjoyed
that like in viserys's last moments part
of the issue with viserys and Allison
and the misunderstanding here is that
there's too many bloody aegons
um because viserys is talking about
aegon the first but Alison thinks that
he's talking about her son Alison her
son aegon the Elder he's called uh but
there's also now another aegon who is
called aegon the younger who is the son
of rhaenyra and Daemon
um and then you know there's also aegon
Theon crowned who was killed by maegor
previously and then like after that
there's aegon the fourth and and Fifth
and so and then Jon Snow was apparently
called aegon Targaryen in the show Canon
so many bloody aegons so really House
Targaryen brought this on themselves
uh and you know like the whole you know
Rainier and Daemon naming their their
son aegon is it is a political act to
rival uh Alison's son aegon because you
know calling your kid aegon is a symbol
of like positioning your child as a
Targaryen king
um so naming their kid aegon he that
sort of makes that kid a rival
um and a rival claimant to the throne
against
um Alison's child aegon
thanks for the Super Chat from kyos
ballerina who says still no dayron yeah
so in the books there is a fourth child
of viserys and Allison called dayron
um and he's like the one who isn't a
[ __ ] he's like he's just sort of a
good-natured nice kid who Everyone likes
as opposed to aegon and aim onto a
terrible
um and I I think that dayron probably
will turn up at some point because there
are four bloodstreams
um coming from Alison in the opening
sequence uh at the start of each episode
uh suggesting that there are four kids
uh of Allison just like in the books uh
yeah here it's very small and blurry but
that represents Alison and those four
blood streams I think represent her four
children so I think that dayron does
exist in hot day we just haven't seen
him yet and it's possible that dayron is
currently
um at Old Town because he gets fostered
at Old Town in the books so he might
turn up later uh thanks for the Super
Chat from tadpole who says vemond
getting his head cut in half made me
audibly gasp wow and I love the channel
thanks for the great content thank you
tadpole yeah I thought it was wonderful
uh how viserys was like uh I will have
your tongue vemond will cut out your
tongue for saying that Jason Luca
bastards and then viserys just then then
Daemon out of nowhere just cuts vemon's
head in half which was like whoa and I
yeah I was not expecting that because
that is a change from the books
um the way that that went down
um but I liked I liked I liked the way
vemon's head just got goddamn chopped in
half like a piece of fruit just like
cleanly through his skull because that
reminds us that like Valerian steel is
extremely sharp and extremely strong
more than regular steel it's like a you
know the westerosi equivalent of a
lightsaber
um it reminds us that there is a
difference between Valyrian steel and
regular steel
um dark sister is the name of daemon's
Valyrian steel sword and so I liked
seeing that you know seeing its
sharpness and I also enjoyed the way
they used the valerion succession crisis
because this is a little bit different
compared to in the books
um but I like how you know the high
Towers were using the the valerion
succession crisis like will vemon
valerion be the next Lord of driftmark
or will Luke valerion Rhone era's son be
the next Lord of driftmark and the high
Towers like Alison and Otto were using
this as a way to erode Jace and Luke and
rhaenyra's claims to the throne because
the high Towers were going okay like if
we give drift Mark to vemond instead of
to Luke that sort of suggests that Luke
is not legitimate without actually
saying that Luke is not legitimate like
if we disinherit Luke of driftmark the
next step is to disinherit Jace of the
throne and rhaenyra of the throne so
it's it's smart it's a sort of like a
Prelude it's like a gradual slope
towards you know just gradually eroding
Rainier as families legitimacy it's a
very sneaky Otto Hightower sort of a
play so I I thought it was smart the way
they used that and also like you know if
they give on drift Mark then they could
form an alliance with vemond because
vemond would owe them his lordship so
they would have the powerful valerion
Fleet on their side
so you know it it sort of largely goes
unspoken but it's a smart plot by the
high Towers to sort of steal the
alliance of the valerions from uh
Rainier's side and I thought it was
interesting like rainis position through
all of this
um because you know it was kind of crazy
it was kind of crazy when when Rainier
and day one were talking like because I
remember last episode Daemon and Rainier
are faked uh the death of Lenor valerion
and Rainier was saying and Daemon was
saying that everyone's gonna think that
rhaenyra and Daemon murdered lane or
valerion so that Rainier could marry
Daemon
and we were wondering like will rainey's
and Corliss think that rhaenyra and
Daemon murdered their son Lano or are
they gonna like explain like hey uh we
actually didn't murder your son it's all
cool and apparently Rainier did not tell
rhaenys that she did not murder her son
lanor uh she just now like six years
later comes up to rhaenys and says uh
hey
um hey you know how you think that I
murdered your son yeah no I didn't like
why are you just saying that now Rainier
um and rainey's you know seems to think
it's too little too late and rainy does
not welcome Rainier's proposed Alliance
like Rainier says here hey like rainey's
you should support me and my son Luke
and we should be Pals and we should
marry Jace to Baylor and marry Luke to
Raynor but rainy says like no [ __ ] off
and I really liked the subtle Thunder
that was in the background like there's
a storm brewing and we heard thunder
while rainy's was on screen a few times
which calls back to rhaenys's Baratheon
Heritage because rainey's Targaryen is
the daughter of Jocelyn Baratheon and
you know the baratheons are associated
with storms and storms and so I thought
that Thunder was a really great way of
sort of tying into rhaenys's Heritage
and her sort of strength and her
Defiance and her family was really cool
but then rhaenys changes her mind
because later on
um in the throne room rainey's
unexpectedly says you know what I'm
actually supporting uh Luke and rhaenyra
not vemond which was nice and yeah like
Corliss is wounded so we're hoping that
he won't die in the books he's more just
like sick because he's old Corliss is
quite quite old at this point in the
books but yeah whatever thanks for the
Super Chat from communist who says when
the Doom fell on valyria our house
became the last of their kind
yeah we've got some more house celtagar
Erasure because uh yeah so the valerians
and the targaryens are Valyrian they
came from the Great Dragon Lord Empire
of old valyria and when the Doom of
valyria blew him up uh the targaryens
and the valerians survived because they
had earlier come to Westeros but they
are not the only Valyrian families who
escaped to Westeros there was also a
house called keltergar so crabs in the
chat folks because the sigil of House
celtagar is a crab and the Celtic guys
are cool they've got like a Valyrian
steel ax and everything but uh the the
valerians and the targaryens keep saying
no we are the last Valyrian houses
ignoring the existence of the celticos
the the show runner Ryan condle has
acknowledged this he said that uh the
celticas do exist in a hot day it's just
they're not very powerful so no one
cares
uh thanks the sex row but no spoilers
here interesting thought though thanks
for the Super Chat from Liam who says he
paid his Penance for his wife's death he
battled the stepstones for 20 years he
is busy tea and he is my king from this
day until my last day
I love how viserys was not very
confident but he is very likable and I I
think that he did a wonderfully
charismatic performance
thanks for the Super Chat from curl who
says viserys's face rot was on the side
of the high Towers at the table and on
Alison's bedside symbolism yeah that
that's probably not a coincidence
um oh this shot by the way is uh
straight out of one of the illustrations
in Fire and Blood
um
that was
Alison and Rainier Fire and Blood
there's a shot that looks yeah there we
go there's an illustration by Doug
Wheatley that looks um just like this
shot with rhaenyra and Alison doesn't it
this was in some of the trailers and
there's even the pig in the illustration
actually which is funny because later
they put a roast Pig down in front of
amond I wonder if that pig illustration
is where they got the idea for the uh
Pink dread being cooked up in front of
aemond that's fun
uh thanks for the Super Chat from shade
who says yeah that's that's something
that's going to come up later thanks for
the Super Chat from Christian who says
do you think viserys abdicating as his
health declined in favor of rhaenyra
would have prevented the dance that it I
think that's a good idea because like
the issue is that no matter what viserys
says his wishes are people may not
follow his wishes after he dies but if
viserys was actually around to say hey
like you know I'm in poor health I'm
gonna abdicate so that my air rain era
can take charge you know before I die
and he would have been able to actually
oversee the transition and actually
support rhaenyra through the transition
I think that's a good idea although
there's no uh precedent for that in
Targaryen history like there is no
Targaryen King who was King and then
gave up being King in favor of someone
else while they were still alive at
least to my memory so yeah I think
that's a decent idea but it's not
something that's been done before so
maybe that's why it can't happen
thanks for the Super Chat from non who
says why don't people name their kids
orus after Oris Baratheon like they do
with aegon yeah so auris Baratheon was a
buddy of aegon the Conqueror when they
uh oh no was that a different yeah no
Oris Baratheon uh he did a cool duel
against argalak of house durandan and uh
oras Baratheon became the founder of
house Baratheon when he defeated the
durandans alongside during aegon's
conquest and Horus was cool why don't
people name name him auris I think part
of the reason is that orus was a bastard
at least before he became the Baratheon
and there's a lot of questions about
auris's parentage like some people think
that orus may have been aegon's
half-brother and some people also
suggest that some people theorize that
orus may have been the real father of
aegon's children like some people
theorize that aegon the Conqueror was
impotent there's also suggestions that
like rhaenys was [ __ ] around so like
there's it's so funny that you know all
this fuss is made about aegon's
bloodline and yet aegon's bloodline may
not have actually been aegons depending
on who you ask and also this speaks to
you know the the connection between
House Targaryen and house Baratheon
which is very old
uh satali points out Jace with his
Valyrian lessons we saw early in the
episode he'd think that they would all
grow up a bilingual
yeah I mean I don't know how I mean do
they need to be speaking High Valyrian
all the time like we see uh rhaenyra and
Daemon talking Valerian a lot which is
like the little sort of intimate
conversational language and you need
Valyrian to command the dragons
um
but you know
I I guess there's some old books that
are probably written in High Valyrian
like Daemon was reading those books in
pentos maybe those are written in High
Valyrian
so yeah I can see how it'd be useful but
not like super essential but what I did
like is it showed us that Jace is really
uh dutiful and determined to be you know
he's Earnest and he wants to do a good
job and so he's taking his studies
seriously and he's trying to be a good
guy I think Jace is is likable in that
respect like he's trying to be a good
heir to the throne and that contrasts
with Alison's son aegon who is useless
and [ __ ] around and is insulting
people so I think Jace is uh definitely
a charismatic sort of a guy speaking
like we were speaking in the previous
episode about Helena's Prophecy with
like the dragons of Flesh and the
dragons of thread
um and there was a moment in this speech
where viserys took off his mask and he
like showed his hideously uh leperous
face and he's like you know look at me
like I am just a man like I know that
I'm a king and the gold and the crown
but beneath that I am just a human flesh
and blood man and I think that connects
with the idea of dragons of Flesh that
Helena was talking about in the previous
episode like the targaryens are dragons
They are Kings they are conquerors but
beneath all of that they are just humans
and that is what viserys was appealing
to his vulnerability and his Humanity
he's a dragon but he's a dragon of Flesh
so I really enjoyed that
thanks for the Super Chat from Lord
Crowe
um yeah I mean I I think this is one of
the better episodes sure thanks for the
Super Chat from James who says can we
talk about how amon's aged like 10 more
years than his siblings yeah
man's sure looking uh sure looking older
I loved his first line like he's uh he's
sparring with Kristen Cole the books
mentioned how amount has become a very
powerful
Warrior under the tutelage of Kristen
Cole because Kristen Cole is this very
powerful Warrior and he's taught amond
everything he knows
um
and
and that's despite the lack of his eye I
think it's pretty ballsy to be facing
off against Kristen Cole's Morning Star
when you've got no depth perception like
is it just me or would that be
incredibly difficult you can't see in 3d
when you've only got one eye trust me I
know
um so I'm shocked that aemond didn't
take a morning start of the face
um but yeah aimond is a really powerful
Warrior and then his first line or one
of his first lines
Kristen says oh you'll be winning Tonys
in no time aemond and then aemon says I
don't give a [ __ ] about Tonys which I
thought was such a great line because it
shows that he is like No Nonsense he
doesn't care about like the the
frivolous activity of attorney what he
cares about is like real fights real
violence real killing real real getting
[ __ ] done I think that one line tells us
a lot about aemond and then he
immediately turns to his nephews and
says Ah you hear the train and so I
think that's you know very much
highlighting his rivalry and his hatred
of Luke who took his eye
um so you get the sense that that's what
he's training for you know
my God
thanks for the Super Chat from misting
who says how long has it been since the
last winter in this timeline that's a
good question I I don't know off the top
of my head you could figure it out by
looking at the book
um that's a good question because of
course in this world the seasons are
irregular sometimes the winters go for
years sometimes the Summers go for years
and especially in the north that's a
really big deal people starve when it's
winter in the north and that affects you
know armies marching as well like
Mobility is less during uh during winter
so yeah that's a good question
um I don't know I don't remember off the
top of my head thanks for the Super Chat
from Brad who says when Daemon helped
his brother up the throne it really
drove home that he does love his family
yeah I agree that was lovely
um Daemon does especially his brother
love his family very much doesn't mean
that daemon's decisions are good for the
family all of the time but Daemon Damon
is definitely motivated by um by love
for his family I mean he didn't love uh
Lena all that much his relationship with
Lena was uh difficult his wife Elena uh
that there was apparently according to
rumor there was a cut scene or a cut
moment where Daemon was uh flirting with
some man some serving man in pentos at
reggio's Feast like there is a moment in
the episode where Daemon sort of like
touches the arm and and Whispers a few
words to this serving man uh which with
the implication being that he's like
cheating on uh cheating on Lena and is a
hashtag bisexual king uh which didn't
there might have been some further stuff
there that was cut from the episode but
um yeah anyway thanks for the Super Chat
from Christopher who says does the whole
ending scene with Alison and viserys
prove that the whole Prince that was
promised is just a wishy-washy dream
reflecting Jon's lackluster conclusion
in season eight
yeah so I've said before that I think
it's interesting that they are
emphasizing the prophecy so much uh
given that the prophecy in the Game of
Thrones show didn't really go anywhere
in the books there is reason to believe
that like you know Jon Snow and or
Daenerys and or others you know the
Danes you know that it it seems like in
the books the prophecy really will go
somewhere
um John might you know wield a flaming
sword and sacrificed Daenerys and defeat
the white walkers but in the Game of
Thrones show I uh jumped out of a tree
and and sparked the night King with with
a bit of Cutlery with the Valyrian steel
catsball blade
um so you definitely can question like
is the prophecy just wishful thinking or
is the prophecy something real and that
is something that the books play with
um I I do think it's interesting that
that viserys in this episode says that
rhaenyra is the one rhaenya is the the
prince that was promised
um which reminds me of when maester Amon
in the books there's a book there's a
moment when Amon says that rain that
that Daenerys is the prince that was
promised he says like oh you know we
were looking for a prince but it's
actually a princess and in the show they
say that like prince and princess uh is
not a gendered word in Valyrian Valyrian
so it could mean either one and so you
know aemon sort of on his deathbed is
like oh my God it's not a prince it's a
princess it's Daenerys is the prince
that was promised and now viserys is
going oh it's Rainier that's the prince
that was promised which is you know that
like that's not that's it's not in the
books but it makes sense because it
seems that every generation of
targaryens thinks that they are the
Fulfillment of the prince that was
promised prophecy like you know rhaegar
and and possibly like like aerys the
first and Jairus the second they all had
their various beliefs about the prophecy
um and uh so it makes sense that viserys
has his own and so you know I don't
think that I don't think they're all
going to be direct about their
interpretation of the prophecy
but is it I am very curious about what
else they're going to reveal about the
prophecy in this show because they've
made it so Central and it is weird for
them to make it so Central if the bottom
line is they were wrong are your stock
is going to do it and the targaryens
were like part of the battle of the long
night but not Central to it so did the
targaryens really need to be on the
throne yeah
like I think it would be unsatisfying if
that is where the prophecy goes so I do
hope that there are
some kind of Revelation but you know it
yeah I think tying things into Game of
Thrones season eight is just not all
that satisfying
thanks for the Super Chat from tulsey
who says that viserys said in an early
episode what if I was wrong I saw aegon
wearing the conquerors crown and now
vicera says aegon is the one so honestly
Alison thinks it's his wish to an extent
yeah Allison's interpretation of this
conversation is that
is that Alison's son aegon is the prince
that was promised and should be the
rightful Heir I mean Ellison doesn't
know what the prince that was promised
is
she doesn't know what adversaris is
talking about here but she thinks that
he's saying that her son aegon is the
one and needs to be on the throne but I
think that's kind of Alison believing
what she wants to believe there I think
she's sort of choosing to believe uh
that he's talking about aegon which kind
of makes Alison the villain here because
Ellison really was genuinely for a
moment trying to reconcile with rhaenyra
and like she was saying like Alison and
rhaenyra were as close as they had been
in ages they're saying hey let's be Pals
again or let's let's just start to not
hate each other so much again like we
would we would like to become closer
it's this beautiful moment but just
afterwards I think that Alison's
ambition is rekindled by viserys and all
of a sudden she's like oh I would
actually like my son to be on the throne
despite my supposed support of rhaenyra
earlier like Alison says at this dinner
uh yeah rhaenyra you're going to be a
great Queen so it seems like she's
letting go of her ambition and actually
the supporting peace and rhaenyra but
then at the end she's like oh my son
aegon on the throne you know it didn't
take much it didn't take much for her to
go right back on to the ambition train
yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from TJ who
says Missouri is spy Talia looks awfully
familiar uncanny resemblance to some
previous well-known characters
so we did have an interesting Revelation
uh that mazaria the white worm is back
and she's continuing to be a spymaster
and this woman Talia who is a handmaiden
she is working for mazario and informing
mazaria of what's going on in the red
keep and I wonder like is mazaria
continuing to feed information to Otto
Hightower like when she told Otto about
Daemon hooking up with rainy era or is
she her own agent now it's been a lot of
years what exactly is mazaria up to and
I wonder what is Missouri's relationship
to Daemon are they still together or not
anymore what is Missouri's game
be interesting to find out I think she
may still have resentment against Daemon
for uh Daemon [ __ ] her around on
Dragonstone and saying that he's gonna
marry her and then not marrying her and
putting her in danger and all of that uh
Philip in the live chat suggests that
mazaria might be working with Laris yeah
I think that's a good theory because you
know Laris knows things about uh you
know Moon tea and the red keep and so on
so maybe mazaria is laris's source of
information I think that makes sense
uh some people in the live chart are
saying that Talia looks like Melisandre
does she look like Melisandre
should we I mean she does have like
reddish hair in that light I suppose
I I I guess there's some resemblance
there
does she look like I think they all look
pretty similar when they're in these uh
candle lit candlelit rooms everyone
looks a little bit red everyone's a red
woman in Candlelight I guess there is
some similarity though yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Philippe
who says thoughts on aegon's
characterization so far I think they
made him too much of a villain with the
maid situation
yeah aegon's not a good guy I mean
aegon's aegon's knocking up the maid it
was was bad uh and it also was bad when
aegon was insulting
um insulting Jace at table and like
propositioning his betrothed at table
while everyone else is trying to make
peace he is blind or or opposed to the
peacemaking that is going on and he's
like actively uh insulting Jace and
Baylor which is uh dick move
um I think that sort of the the context
here is that you know aegon's
relationship with Allison is so toxic
like we've seen Alice and hit aegon
twice now
um and aegon keeps saying oh I like I'm
doing my best I didn't ask to be the to
be the the arrival claimant to the
throne I didn't want any of this and his
mother just keeps hitting him so I think
you know there is some pain in aegon we
see him cry and you know the way that he
expresses that pain is to insult and
Bully others and to knock up serving
girls so yeah he's a horrible person
um but I think that it is important that
they showed us his vulnerability at the
same time as showing us his dickishness
and I think it you know it's fairly
consistent with the way he's described
in the books so yeah I'm pretty happy
with the characterization of aegon and
I'm excited to see what comes next
um
thanks for the Super Chat from Pat who
says that server girl really got the
inside scoop on everything happening
inside the castle I'm guessing Otto is
not aware of this spy yeah I mean Talia
Talia is
like Allison's serving girl primarily I
think so I wonder if Allison has any
knowledge of Talia like if it is that
Talia and mazaria are informing Laris
and Laris is supporting Alison I wonder
if Alison might know that Talia is a spy
but I mean if Allison knows that Talia
is a spy why wouldn't Talia just tell
Alison things directly instead of Talia
telling mazaria telling Laris telling
Allison I I think that Italia and
mazaria might be up to their own game
thanks for the Super Chat from Devon who
says do you think Lena will return
yeah so we don't want to spoil anything
but I I mean it is a change from the
books that Leonor is it is a change from
the books
um I I do think the issue of sea smoke
is important because sea smoke is the
dragon of lanor and
as far as we know a dragon cannot have a
new Rider while
the old rider is still alive as long as
Lenor is alive
sea smoke theoretically should not be
able to take any more Riders and also
theoretically there are hints that
dragons might be able to sense or find
their Rider there's like a psychic Bond
there so I wonder like is sea smoke
gonna go out and try and find lanor I
think that I think that would make sense
so you know I mean I it would be
interesting to me if they addressed that
like what if the dragon Keepers said oh
like sea smoke is acting weird sea smoke
seems upset about lenor's death or like
or like I don't know what if they had a
funeral for Lenor and then see smoke was
at the funeral and like smelling the
corpse and going that's not Lena I don't
know like I would like to see a little
bit more from sea smoke but I mean you
know that is sea smoke is one Dragon
among many so I'm not sure if we'll um
I'm not sure if we'll get any more from
him there but yeah there's some
possibilities with lane or so I'm
interesting to see I'm interested to see
what happens uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Caro who says that amond aged
way faster yeah look the time skips and
the ages don't always make sense because
it's impossible to cast the actors at
like exactly the right ages at exactly
the right Years yet we do have to
suspend our disbelief a little bit I
think thanks for the Super Chat from
Gunner who says the lack of dragons in
this episode is weird I I mean the
dragons are expensive with the CGI so I
I think it's permissible to not have too
much Dragon action all the time but I
expect we'll see more of the Dragons
later thanks for the Super Chat from
what who says the pig being carried in
as the king is being carried off is
wonderful symbolism for how the instant
viserys leaves the family that he so
dearly loves will begin carving
themselves and the realm up yeah that's
a great Point what I agree uh because
you know viserys talked before about
like I will not have these crows
feasting on the corpse of my dead family
um and yeah just as viserys is carried
off the pig is carried in and so that
almost represents viserys's corpse and
everyone dining on viserys's corpse
trying to get their piece of power I
mean you know the the vultures were
descending even before viserys was dead
like what with vemond trying to secure
his uh claim of a drift Mark and so on
so
yeah I think that's a great point it's
very much the vultures descending on
viserys's corpse thanks for the Super
Chat from dongle who says I was digging
the energy between Daemon and amond
they're both wild cards I'm excited to
see how they might interact yeah Daemon
and aemon stared each other down
wonderfully I mean they are I mean
they've got to be the two greatest
warriors in this in this story currently
right like Daemon is is a renowned
fighter and amond is said to be very
powerful
um what with his training by by Kristen
I mean Kristen is also a very great
Fighter
um aegon is is not noted as a great
warrior uh Jace and luceris I mean you
know we'll see we might see more a
little bit later I mean there's the
kingsguard I suppose like you know
Harold westerling his his
strength as a warrior is not described
in the books but he's probably good we
we did get to meet aric and Eric these
new kingsguard this episode actually
um
and they are identical twins Eric and
Eric and they are going to be relevant
later on yeah we got this moment here
where Allison said uh you know hi Eric
and then he said no I'm not Eric I'm
Eric it's funny that like we've got Eric
and Eric being interchangeable like
Alison got confused about arik and Eric
and then at the end of the episode
Alison got confused about aegon and
aegon when viserys was talking about
aegon the Conqueror and she thought he
was talking about aegon her son so we've
got aegon and aegon we've got Eric and
Eric we've got Baylor and Raynor and
Lena and Lenor and we've got rhaenys and
Rainier and Daemon and and [ __ ]
there's so many similar names that there
was a thing in um the interviews where
the co-creators of this show or the
co-showrunners of this show Ryan and
Miguel were talking about hey like there
are so many characters with the same
name or similar names in this show we've
got to change the names of some of these
characters so it's not too confusing uh
but the co-show runner Ryan condle said
absolutely not we are not changing any
names we are staying faithful to the
books and uh you know you know honestly
I would not blame them if they decided
to change some names like I've seen
online people like misspelling and
getting confused about who's who I would
not blame them changing some names it's
like when they changed
um
uh uh Asher Greyjoy in the books is
named Yara Greyjoy in the TV show uh
because they didn't want Asha getting
confused with OSHA who is the wildling
like I think it's reasonable to change
some of those names I mean they say when
you write a book you should never have
two characters with the same letter at
the start of their name
um you shouldn't have John and Josh
because that would be too confusing but
I mean George has filled up the whole
alphabet 10 times over so you know he's
breaking every rule
thanks for the Super Chat
Forum Lee who says what's up with Lady
misery I mean we we sort of talked about
her but I I it it seems that she's
continuing to be a spy master and she's
being informed by Italia who's one of
the servants in the red keep and we
don't know who mazaria is working with
is she still informing Otto is she maybe
working with Laris is she may be working
with Allison is she a free agent is she
trying to get revenge on Daemon is she
just trying to make herself wealthy I
like how you know her earrings and her
clothes sort of subtly suggest that you
know she's doing well for herself like
she's made some money she's doing well
um
she could be anywhere if she wanted to I
think I think she's in King's Landing
because she wants to be in King's
Landing so what is her plan there
thanks for the Super Chat from VI we
already talked about the prince that was
promised
um I I if
maybe the prince that was promised is uh
Ned Stark because he fathered Arya who
is lightbringer I don't know thanks for
the Super Chat from Eric or is it Eric
who says I'm team blacks how about you
tell me in the chat whether you support
rhaenyra and her family who are called
the blacks in the books or do you
support Alison and her family who are
called the greens
I have I have a suspicion that it's
going to be more the uh we can do a poll
can't we
um blacks Rainier is family
or greens
Allison's family we're gonna put a poll
in the live chat right now and it is uh
who you support question mark and uh ask
your community
and it's live now you can vote in the
live chat do you support Alison or
Rainier there's a poll and then I'll
tell you what the results are shortly
thanks for the Super Chat from rational
who says King viserys's last day in
court was so moving with his black sheep
brother putting the crown on his head no
less I'm not crying you're crying yeah I
I thought viserys's last walk was really
wonderful when he was you know obviously
in so much pain and discomfort doing
that taking power so much like Risk to
himself but he was so determined to do
the right thing and you know like he's
kind of dumb because it's like well you
could have you should have done this
earlier you know like viserys should
have asserted himself more and you know
it's understandable he was very sick and
he sort of allowed Alice hunting Otto to
do everything for him he wasn't really
able to to take power but
you know and the milk of the poppy
addling his mind and but all you know I
love how he had the moment of taking off
his mask showing his vulnerability
um and just being
a human being and a dad and a husband
and a father
who just reluctantly played the role of
a king he didn't want to be your king he
wasn't good at being a king this was
thrust upon him and that shows you know
what a bad system the monarchy is I mean
it's the same with aegon it's the same
with bloody aegon saying I didn't ask
for this I'm not a good King I never
wanted to be king monarchy puts people
in charge who have no qualifications or
no business being in charge so it's not
surprising that um sometimes you get bad
results uh we have 4 000 people have
voted in this Poll for the blacks or the
greens and 87 of Voters support rhaenyra
and her family not Allison and her
family we should do this every episode
to see if the these poll number changes
four thousand people have voted and 87
percent support Rainier over Allison
and I think that's not shocking given
that viserys the King has so clearly
sort of put his support behind rhaenyra
I mean you know not always clearly but
he has always supported rhaenyra and
Allison's Alison's moment at the end of
the episode saying oh you want my son
aegon to be king that that is so much
her hearing what she wants to hear that
is so much her you know twisting
viserys's word that's not what viserys
meant I think Alison does have you know
legitimate reason to feel angry at
Rainier because Rainier I mean
fundamentally Alison is correct that
rhaenyra's children are bastards and
rhaenyra is a liar and rhaenyra is a
rule breaker and Allison is a religious
person who believes that Rainier has
sinned grievously
um and there's the fact that a lot of
the Kingdom won't support a female ruler
doesn't don't want a female ruler like
that that is still at issue here and so
just by fact of being female rhaenyra B
being the ruler will be destabilizing
and a bit risky compared to a male being
on the throne and it's not Rainier's
fault of course that you know this is a
patriarchal world uh but it's a fact and
so you know I think there are arguments
in support of Alison's side
but uh yeah I tend to agree with the
audience that Rainier is more is more
sympathetic at this point
thanks for the Super Chat from Fack who
says how do you think Corliss will react
coming home to find his brother dead I
mean call us and vemon did not always
get along
um and if callus knew that vemond was
trying to steal driftmark from corliss's
chosen Heir Luke yeah I don't know if
course is going to be weeping Too Many
Tears for vemond
um I mean you know he's he's an
honorable guy and vaimond is his brother
so he's not going to be happy that
vemond was killed dishonorably I mean
it's also interesting you know Daemon is
the one who killed Vermont and it was
kind of murder because like viserys did
not tell anyone to kill vemon viserys
told viserys wanted vemon's tongue cut
out but then Daemon just killed him on
the spot which I mean that's murder that
wasn't what the king asked for
um I don't think anyone's gonna gonna
take Daemon to court for that particular
murder but I mean you know my point is
that since Carlos and Daemon are all
lies or at least former allies and
friends I call this might be angry at
Daemon for killing his brother in Cold
Blood and you know especially
considering the fact that Corliss and
rhaenys still apparently think
up until this episode that rhaenyra and
Daemon murdered their son Lenor in the
previous episode maybe Corliss is going
to be pissed maybe Corliss will consider
Daemon his enemy now I think there's a
few ways that um
he might take it
so yeah I don't know I think that the
valerion relationship is uh certainly
complicated Now by recent events thanks
for the Super Chat from Greg who says
are Baylor and Rayna not twins in the
show The Arena actresses at both ages
seem younger than the Baylor actresses
um I I think they're twins
they haven't said anything otherwise
um
so you reckon that Reina looks younger
yeah I guess I would agree with that I
mean Rainer is meant to be younger by
about five seconds it is I mean that's
one of the other fun things about the
the Ridiculousness of the monarchy
um that literally being the twin who
comes out of the womb first can
determine whether you inherit a lordship
or a throne or whether you inherit next
to nothing
um so the whole twin thing is something
that they play with with you know like
Cersei and and Jamie and with Eric and
Eric so you know twin hood is is going
to be a thing but yeah Baylor is the
elder twin so she is the one who is um
potentially gonna well was potentially
gonna inherit drift mark But now the
plan is that Jace is going to marry
Baylor and Luke is going to marry Rayna
and you know that is a way of like
binding up the disagreements the uh you
know the slight murder kerfuffle between
house valerion and Targaryen and to bind
together these families again which
which is which is a different situation
to how it worked in the books in the
books there was this wonderful
friendship between rhaenyra and Daemon
and Lena and Baylor and Rayna because
when Daemon and Lena were married they
hung out on driftmark for a while and
rhaenyra was on Dragonstone so they were
like neighbors and like their their
families hung out together and Loki like
Daemon and rainyro might have been
[ __ ] around on the side but you know
there was this friendship between
rhaenyra's family and
um Daemon and and you know lane or like
they're all friends together and that's
part of what led to this betrothal that
happens between Rainier's kids and
daemon's kids
um and there's also slight hints that
Lena and raniera may even even have been
like romantically of involved maybe
because rhaenyra was quote fond and more
than fond of Lena so uh yeah I mean if
you want to ship if you want to ship
anyone with anyone you can in the books
because there's a lot of sort of
ambiguous romantic relationships
thanks for the Super Chat from bifong
who says they've done an awesome job
showing the tragedy with viserys trying
to make everyone happy but seeing
everything slowly fall apart in front of
him even viserys's body parts are
literally falling apart in front of him
yeah it's it's tragic I think the part
that I found the most sad was when
rhaenyra walked into
viserys's bedroom and saw his uh model
City
his valyria city which is like his pride
and joy his little Warhammer hobby hobby
is model train set and
viserys you know this was viserys's
passion and then when rhaenyra comes
home and like visits uh viserys and sees
her father for the first time in a long
time she sees cobwebs and she sees a rat
and she sees like the dilapidation that
that her father's pride and joy has
fallen into which is it just feels so
sad because that's just such a mark of
how far viserys has fallen
um you know if you've ever had a loved
one who has given up on their Hobby and
given up on the thing that gives them
Joy I think that's such a painful sign
of someone being unwell and I think
that's what rhaenyra is observing in her
own father as he's getting older so I
thought that was a really poignant sad
moment
and you know it also ties into the
symbolism of valyria itself which was
this Empire that was so powerful and so
full of dragons and then it fell
calamitously and I think that the
cobwebs and the mice you know
on the model of valyria suggests the
inevitable fall of all Empires and the
downfall that may one day come to House
Targaryen because of course we know that
you know by the time of the Game of
Thrones show uh there are no more
dragons anymore and there are very few
targaryens left anymore so you know
something happened to to cause a decline
in House Targaryen so maybe that we
witnessed some of that uh we'll close
the poll now 87 of you voted for
rhaenyra as opposed to Alison we'll
we'll do that poll again another time
and see if the numbers change
thanks for the Super Chat from Lucas who
says do you think Alison's deference to
rangiora was legitimate was she being
honest in accepting her as viserys's
Heir or was she just playing along to
make corpse corpse hubby happy
yeah I mean you could speculate that
Alison was being duplicitous and was
just pretending to be friendly to
rhaenyra but I tend to think that in the
moment Alison was being sincere I think
Alison really did want to make peace
because like because I think what was so
wonderful and tragic about this dinner
scene is that the adults
would were moved by viserys's words and
by viserys's ill health I think the
adults being a bit more mature and being
a bit more grown up they they and being
more emotionally connected to viserys
like it really does move them to see
viserys dying and that really does
inspire Allison and rhaenyra to try to
make peace to try and make things better
um I think that the adults have a better
sense of their own mortality and not
wanting to risk what they have like like
Allison Terraria they are mothers they
have children now even Daemon has
children now maybe he has even mellowed
out so like rhaenyra and Allison have so
much more to lose now like they are not
just feuding teenagers anymore they are
a bit more grown up and so I think that
Allison and Rainier are sincere to a
large extent in trying to make peace and
support each other but the kids you know
Jace and Luke and amond they are not
grown up they do not have as much to
lose they have no sense of their own
mortality
all they have is [ __ ] testosterone
and you know what was rhaenys's line in
episode one Fists Full Of Steel and
balls full of seed I think amont has the
steel and aemon and aegon has the seed
in this case
but it was the kids who continued the
inertia of the conflict whilst the
adults were trying to make Pace because
the kids are not grown up the kids are
not mature the kids are not moved by
aegons by viserys's vulnerability so
yeah I thought it was really great the
way that that Feast scene went down
uh Sid says where viserys's eye do you
think it just fell out one day like
rolled under the bed maybe you could
just fetch it and pop it back in maybe
maybe amond wants viserys's eye to
replace the eye that he lost maybe amond
took viserys's eye you know and of
course I think that you know the the
bandage that was over viserys is missing
eye you know that implies blindness you
know viserys is not fully aware of
what's going on around him so his lost
eye definitely speaks to that I think
thanks for the Super Chat from Nono who
says aegon ordered that the trees should
be killed Feld burned them all I bet the
weirwood in the garden is a planted spy
the three-eyed Raven his weirwood are
the true enemy
yeah no no so uh so you know trees uh
the trees have eyes literally they've
got they've got faces and the old gods
can see through the weirwoods the green
Cedars can see through the weirwoods uh
bloodraven has not been born yet but the
green seers can see through time to some
extent so it is entirely plausible that
bloodraven the three-eyed Raven and bran
could be watching these events from the
weirwood I it would not Shock me if they
actually did some subtle nod to
bloodraven or bran
in this show somehow through the
weirwood at some point but yeah like you
know this weirwood tree
um does not exist in the main Game of
Thrones show so someone must have cut
down this tree at some point uh we
actually do see a weirwood stump in Game
of Thrones season three episode four
that Sansa is praying too it doesn't
look like the same exact location but
you know this is what remains perhaps of
uh this Wayward Tree in Hot D so you
know maybe when Jace was talking about
trees being felled I mean I I think in
that case aegon the Conqueror was
talking about like
um felling the trees around the
Blackwater Rush uh so that
um King's Landing could be built because
aegon just like landed uh on Blackwater
Bay and then was like hey let's let's
build a city here
um and that meant cutting down a bunch
of trees so like you know I I don't
think that that line was referring to
wheelwood trees specifically
but um yeah it does make us wonder about
the Weir Woods thanks for the Super Chat
from Talia who says Jace and Helena
dancing showing us what could have been
at their wedding Feast yeah it's a great
Point Dalia because uh rhaenyra proposed
marriage between Helena and Jace and
it's it's really lovely to see them
getting along
um and dancing and having a good time
here it's like well if Jace and Helena
did marry if Alison did accept that
proposition then maybe these families
could have been United and this could
have been a beautiful relationship but I
don't know if Jace is being entirely
pure in his dance with Elena here
because Jace who was being taunted by
aegon who was insulting Jace and his
betrayal to Baylor so I think that Jace
may have been dancing with Helena as a
way to aggravate aegon like you know you
insulted my betrothed so I'm going to
you know like like aegon aegon was like
mocking and like propositioning sex with
Jace's betrothed Baylor so I think that
Jace was like well if you're gonna like
hit on my betrothed I'm gonna hit on
Your Wife by dancing with Elena
so I don't know if that was all pure but
the dancing was uh the dancing was very
cute and it's nice to see Helena
behaving like a like a person and having
fun so all of that was all of that was
good uh thanks for the donation from
Gotham who says whenever amond and
Daemon green uh they grin when the other
is doing something chaotic they have a
mutual respect for each other I think
respect might be a bit of a generous use
of the word between Daemon and amond
um but I think they certainly understand
each other I think there certainly is
some similarity between Daemon and
aemond they both have some extremely
large chips on their shoulder and they
both exercise violence as a way of
dealing with their feelings so um
maybe they'll be friends
thanks for the Super Chat from otaku who
says the beasts beneath the boards are
larris's rats
are rats beasts I feel like rats are too
small to be beasts but uh there's a few
fun different ways to interpret Helena's
comments about the Beast beneath the
boards thanks Devon and prester who says
the arik and Eric thing is funny I
worked with an Australian guy and people
named Aaron and Aaron they sound the
same in my accent not his yeah I like
the different pronunciations of aegon or
aegon some people say aegon I thought it
was ridiculous the pronunciations of
jeheris
um like viserys and Paddy considine in
hot day keep saying jahiris instead of
jeheris I think jahiris jahiris jaharis
jahiris jahiris there's a lot of weird
ways that people say that name I mean
just for the record
um George R Martin the author of Game of
Thrones he doesn't say Dothraki he says
Dothraki
Dothraki to me that seems ridiculous but
he's the author so how can we argue
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Jaden
who says was viserys talking about Jon
Snow in the prophecy of the prince that
was promised seeing as aegon is Jon's
real name I think that viserys was
talking about aegon the Conqueror and
like aegon's dream because he said that
rhaenyra is the prince that was promised
not not aegon you are the one you must
do this viscerist said thinking that he
was talking to Rainier it is you so I
think that viserys was saying that that
rhaenyra is the is the prince that was
promised and when aegon when viserys
said aegon he was referring to aegon the
Conqueror who like made the prophecy so
I yeah I don't think that viserys is
talking about Jon Snow here uh but yeah
I mean theoretically Jon Snow may be the
prince that was promised ultimately in
some sense at least uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Silva who says viserys
tried to paper over the Powder Keg he
created yeah yeah I think that's a
reason herbal description of what
viserys does because like at the last
minute he tries to make peace he tries
to fix everything but that doesn't undo
the Decades of his failure to lay down
the law and to make peace and to make
some you know more clear binding
statements I mean like remember in
episode one when viserys held that whole
ceremony with rhaenyra and he got all of
those Lords to swear loyalty to rhaenyra
like that's what's needed if if viserys
is serious about rhaenyra taking the
throne he needs to do that again I mean
he shouldn't have to do it twice but you
know he he should have a big ceremony
and he should say I want you know
because because some of the Lords who
are here like all those years ago who
came and swaranera some of those Lords
are dead now so what vizeras should do
is have another big ceremony and get all
of the sons and all of the current Lords
and all of their heirs and bring them to
King's Landing and say hey
rhaenyra is my chosen Heir and her
children Jace and Luke are the uh The
Heirs after her like Jace who's next on
the throne Luke is gonna take over drift
Mark they are legitimate maybe he should
even legitimize them like this is what
vasera should do in order to try and
create some peace and stability behind
rhaenyra and I think that his little
Thanksgiving dinner uh isn't is not
enough so yeah I agree with you silver
scale he should have done more
thanks for the Super Chat from Sam who
says Alison going back to war mode
seemed like an easy way out writing wise
for Sarah's coming in to save the day
I'm gonna miss him yeah I mean it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens next episode because Alison you
know Alison hasn't done anything yet
like we've seen her with this errors
we've seen her interpret viserys's words
as being supportive of aegon but I think
there's still a lot more to happen
um I think there's a lot of reasoning
that's going to go behind Allison's
decisions and remember like Allison is
very much influenced by
Otto and influenced by Alaris and
influenced by Kristen so I think that
all of that is going to be relevant for
Alison going forward and I I do like
that we had this moment of
attempted reconciliation between Allison
and rhaenyra which um I sure hope won't
seem tragic in hindsight
thanks for the Super Chat from ABE who
says most of this episode felt like pure
Exposition a lot of telling not a lot of
showing I thought that the feast was a
lot of showing like we really saw some
of these characters opinions change in
real time you know like Alice and
Rainier's feelings towards each other
and towards viserys
um and you know the the vemond
confrontation was very much happening
before our eyes as vaimond felt pushed
to the point of having to you know say
the bastardy I think there is always
like some feeling of exposition with the
time skip episodes because like
inevitably they have to explain to us
what happened in the meantime so like
when you know rhaenys was saying you
know no I'm not going to support urania
because I think that you murdered my son
Leno there has to be a bit of exposition
there
um but I enjoyed it like this was a
relatively like action light episode it
was really just entirely conversation
there were no you know dragons or fights
or battles or anything no sex scenes
either there were no tits or dragons
um but I uh I think it was one of the
more effective episodes personally
thanks for the Super Chat from Heather
who says I hate the greens and I love
the blacks at least rhaenyra is somewhat
reasonable the greens are always awful
I mean they certainly are uh more more
there's more [ __ ] with the greens
like aegon is a [ __ ] with his
insults and he's knocking up the serving
girl aemond is a violent provocateur
trying to destabilize the kingdom trying
to get revenge against Luke uh Helena is
uh harmless
um but yeah I mean Jace and Luke
certainly are more likable and heroic
than aemond and aegon so yeah I think
there's a lot of good reasons to support
the blacks but again like the blacks are
lying uh rhaenyra is lying about Jace
and Luke their parentage like Alison is
correct that they are bastards so that
is relevant too thanks for the Super
Chat from Brian who says that viserys's
mask was like the Phantom of the Opera
mask thanks for the Super Chat from
Jessica who says this episode makes
Ellison less sympathetic and a hypocrite
with covering up the rape of the serving
Girl by aegon and use of the Moon tea
yeah there's a there's a lot there's a
lot going on with with Alice and you
know enforcing uh the the sort of
patriarchal rules of you know women uh
being used by men sexually and then
Alison you know covers up the secret of
her son Prince aegon uh [ __ ] around
um whereas with rhaenyra's infidelity a
Allison to us all you must be honest and
you must tell the truth and you know you
must be held accountable for your sins
whereas with her own son aegon she is
complicit in covering it up you know and
she just sort of accepts the status quo
I mean she's angry that aegon is
sleeping around and whatever but
yeah I'll listen to his has become part
of the system and an enforcer of the
system
that covers up the crimes that she was
so angry at rhaenyra for
for perpetrating
thanks for the Super Chat from all your
base who says did vemond have any kids
that is a good question that may be
relevant later like vemond has been
beheaded or at least the top half of his
head was removed
um so you know he's dead but maybe
Vermont will have some family of his own
who might have opinions about who should
get drift marks so yeah we should not
assume that this valerion succession
crisis is over necessarily it might be
uh just beginning
thanks for the Super Chat from Gotham
who's and I'll note that in the books
vemond is callus's cousin not his
brother so they made it a bit more
personal and a bit more intimate between
vaymond and Corliss in the show
uh we answered that thanks for the Super
Chat from Thai Lisa who says why was
rainey's glued to vemon's body being
prepared thanks for the chat I enjoy
your videos yeah that's a good question
that they did spend a lot of time with
rhaenys watching vemon's corpse or the
the two pieces of of
vamon's corpse I mean vemond is her
brother-in-law vemond is the brother of
her husband Corliss and I think I think
rhaenys is thinking she may be thinking
about like Legacy like her husband
called This is obsessed with Legacy and
obsessed with his name and obsessed with
you know Luke valerion being the next
Lord of driftmark and I think rhaenys is
sort of contemplating I mean you know
she has said over and over hey Carlos
your Ambitions are gonna get our family
killed
um and you know she's worried about her
own kids but now vemond has been killed
as a result of these clashes and stuff
and so I think you know something that
comes up a lot in A Song of Ice and Fire
is that the the men keep on you know
doing these fights and getting people
killed and the women are dragged along
with her we saw that with Emma dragged
along with viserys's ambitions and we
saw Alison dragged along with Otto's
Ambitions and rhaenys has dragged along
with corliss's ambitions and she sees
the cost of that and I'm not sure that
Corliss does but maybe corliss's mind
will change when he sees vemond the
various pieces of veymont
CC in the live chat says that rhaenys
thinks it's an omen
Holland says that rhaenys is numb to
death yeah yeah because rhaenys has lost
her son Lenor she's lost her son her
daughter Elena she has suffered so much
and here's just a more bodies piling up
you know
so how's she going to react to that is
she going to become like more protective
and more afraid or is she going to
become more YOLO and more violent you
know I mean she threw in her lot with
rhaenyra in this episode like At first
she was against Rainier but then she's
like [ __ ] it like I support Luke and
Jace marrying Baylor and Reina like
we're on the side of Rainier
so you know I wonder what her reasoning
is there like is she no longer afraid of
all this death has she already lost so
much that she is not even afraid of
losing more
I I really enjoyed seeing rainey's as
like the tough politician side of her
like we the episode opened with like her
on the Driftwood throne and it seems
that while Corliss is off at War and the
stepstones rhaenys has been holding down
the fort on driftmark and you know I
think that that's a fun uh contrast to
rhaenys in previous episodes where like
I thought that her her entrance to
driftmark
um in episode five was was so gorgeous
when she like flounced through the door
in the most sort of just fun and
flamboyant way if possible going ah
cousin how are you doing like she's so
just warm and fluffy uh I I really
enjoyed her performance there and it's
such a stark contrast when rhaenys has
to play the politician and you know
maybe her whole personality has just
darkened as a result of the loss of her
children like that changes someone like
no one should have to lose one child let
alone live to see a two of their
children die under horrific
circumstances so maybe rainys has just
become like a darker colder person
that's so sad to see after the
wonderfully joyous side of her we saw
earlier
thanks for the Super Chat from Ron Sands
who says do you think the feud between
the blackwoods and brackens comes back
in this season or future Seasons uh well
it's in the books and I don't want to
spoil anything but uh it's not for no
reason the the brackens and the
blackwoods appeared
um in episode four we saw this fight
between a Blackwood kid and a Bracken
and then it was mentioned again in a
later episode
um and and you know I think part of what
this is is that they've showed us over
and over that
so much of the realm is eager for war so
much of the realm just cannot wait to
start murdering each other because you
know just as the targaryens and the
valerions and the hightowers have their
own feuds and their own Ambitions like
that is just a microcosm of the realm
writ large which is a even Messier even
more angry and complicated
um bunch of ambitious people with even
less to lose and even more grudges in
history like you know everything that's
that that is happening in the red keep
that there's just as much anger and
bloodshed and hatred going on everywhere
else and after this long period of Peace
many are eager for War and the
blackwoods and brackens
four amongst them a foremost amongst
those who want war
so uh yeah I I don't think we've seen
the last of the blackwoods and brackets
thanks for the Super Chat from Alex who
says it's BS that rhaenyra gets in so
much trouble for being a woman but she's
allergic to responsibility are we
talking about rate are you talking about
rhaenys or Rayna or rhaenyra Alex
that goes double for aegon whoever wins
the realm loses well I can agree with
that like I I mean yeah I mean rhaenyra
had a moment here where she was crying
by viserys's bed just going like I I
didn't I didn't want to be out of the
throne I didn't want any of this the
burden is so heavy why do I have to
carry this if you're not supporting me
properly
um
and so yeah like is it a good thing for
the realm terrain for Rainier to be in
charge is it a good thing for aegon or
Allison to be in charge I mean I do note
that Allison has said a few times like
what is best for the realm like when she
was telling viserys hey stop worrying
about your petty issue with Daemon go
and take the stepstones Go and Kill crab
feeder if crab feed is bad for the realm
let's kill crab feeder and I think
Allison in this episode said something
along the lines of we must consider
what's good for the people of the realm
so you know Alison is one of the few
people who's actually considering hey
like we are a government
like like in between all of the feuds
and the feasts and the ballrooms and the
cheating and the lying like like
someone's got to be the government and
we have seen Allison playing that role
you know like we see her at the small
Council going like hey like let's get
some [ __ ] done let's try to do the right
thing so you know we've got to give
Ellison some credit for that I think
pure rhetoric Sam says in the live chat
I mean Allison was very dismissive of uh
poor Lyman beesberry and his exhaustive
accounting on the small Council but um
you know I still think Alison just
clearly putting some work in here and
deserves some acknowledgment for that
another issue that they brought up like
with this for Larry on uh
issue you know vemon saying hey like I
should get to rule driftmark because I'm
actually a valerion but like another
issue is that Luke who is you know
supposedly going to be the next Lord of
driftmark Luke is not qualified to be
the lord of the tides like Luke has
grown up on driftmark and in the red
keep he's not like call us who grew up
on ships and on driftmark like if he's
gonna lead the the Navies of the world
of of the valerions surely he should you
know he should have gotten some
experience in that area but he doesn't
have it like he's obviously not valerion
he obviously doesn't have the experience
so you know I think that's just more
reasons why we can be sympathetic to
vemond because he is speaking sense and
he is speaking truth when he says that
Luke is should not be the Lord of
driftmark
thanks for the Super Chat from someone
in the live chat says Alison is great if
you like Catholicism yeah the faith of
the servant is just it's just
Catholicism with a slightly different
hat it's just Catholicism with a
numerological bent George Martin just
took Catholicism shaved off some filing
and shaved off the serial number and or
I don't know maybe it's [ __ ]
anglicanism it's it's it's some
Christian Christianity flavor that he's
just called the faith of the seven
um and the whole sort of fractious
relationship between the church and the
targaryens is similar to the fractious
relationship between the the church and
the you know various Kings of Europe I
think thanks for the Super Chat of
rabid chew is that what happens to a to
a Pikachu if it gets rabies who says I
think they've done an excellent job
setting up the personalities of the
children
can't wait to see more aemond team black
all the way
yeah I think they've done a good job as
well I would like to see more from Luke
we have not seen a whole lot about what
Luke's deal is
um Jace seems to be a bit more you know
he's he's the big brother so he's the
more sort of confident dutiful one who's
you know trying to trying to do the
right thing whereas Luke seems to have
more doubts like I really I really felt
for Luke when vemond was like shouting
like hey Luke you're not [ __ ] you should
not be the ruler of driftmark and like
you know I mean we saw in the previous
episode like Luke was saying I don't
want to be the Lord of driftmark I don't
want more of my family to die poor
little Luke like that's him and now he's
grown up and it's like I don't think
he's any more convinced now that he
wants to be the Lord of driftmark than
he was previously
but you know as is constantly the theme
the kids are being dragged along so uh
with the adults Ambitions thanks for the
Super Chat from promises who says what
did viserys mean at the end when he
muttered no more and then when he said
my love I think I think when visera said
my love I think he was talking about
Emma I mean like if Sarah's thought that
he was talking to rhaenyra at first
Emma's Emma's daughter and the actor and
the showrunners have talked about
viserys being very much
um in love with Emma still
so I think he was talking about Emma but
like in terms of no more like I I think
no more
I don't know I guess I guess viserys
could have been saying like no more
conflict no more violence like I want my
family to be
together I want no more Division I want
no more of this crap I wonder if also on
some level he's saying no more pain I
wonder if viserys like knows that he's
dying on some level he's saying like no
more like I can't take it anymore I
can't take any more of this pain no more
he's sort of accepting death welcoming
death his death has been a very slow
painful long process he might welcome
death
uh maybe he's he's quoting Poe never
more never more I don't know what do you
guys think viserys was saying yeah you
guys are saying no more pain in the chat
no more being alive no more torment no
more milk of the poppy yeah that's a
good point because he was saying earlier
like I don't want any more of the milk
of the poppy painkiller because it's
like messing with his faculties so yeah
I think there's like several
interpretations no more milk of the
poppy no more pain no more division
No More Cowbell okay thanks guys
thanks for Super Chat from Luke who asks
about the cannibal yeah well look we
won't spoil anything but uh there's
there's more dragons to come uh I don't
know what the exact Dragon situation is
um at this point but like in the books
at least by this point
aegon and Helena have some young
children who have some young dragon
hatchlings of their own but uh you know
we'll see more of the Dragon situation
as it develops uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Robbie did we see Harold
westerling this episode
think we did thanks for the super jump
from Marcus who says in episode 6 when
larus and Alison are talking Talia the
maid entered the room and Laris went
silent possible rivalry between Laris
and mazaria
yeah that's a good point like at the
time I thought that you know Talia might
have been working with larus but yeah
maybe Laris and mazaria are like
competing spy Masters maybe there's only
room for one master of Whisperers in
town and uh larrison Missouri are
opposed to each other yeah there's this
whole sort of undercurrent you know but
we're the Beast beneath the boards
there's this whole undercurrent of the
sort of control of information in this
world and uh yeah Laris and mazaria are
like Google and Mata or something you
know Google and apple Google and Bing
iPod and Zune who will you choose Claris
or mazaria
excellent Super Chat from Lou Who says
why did they cast amond to look as
though he's 35 years old and in a biker
gang
yeah well look I think amond amond is is
a 35 year old biker at heart uh it may
not make sense for him to look that old
that quickly but I think that uh I think
that he is perfectly cast as an absolute
[ __ ] who wants to ruin your day
because that's what he is it's I I think
that that's the most important thing
thanks for the Super Chat from Michael
who says how did Otto scam his way into
being hand of the King again we talked
about this in the previous explained
video like he he just did the easy thing
like it was just easy to let Otto take
power again because he knows Otto and he
knows that Otto is biased towards Alison
but viserys does not find the strength
inside himself to actually oppose Otto
so he's just like fine and like Alison
would have wanted Otto Allison was very
clear earlier that she wanted Otto to be
handed the King again so
viserys just did the easy thing and
that's another thing that we can
criticize viserys for because if viserys
was serious about supporting rhaenyra as
Heir he should not have allowed Otto to
be hand given that Otto opposes rhaenyra
so you know that's that's on viserys I
think uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Icy who wonders if there might be a
rivalry between amond and Daemon yeah I
don't think that that there's enough
room in town for two men with such
enormous egos uh in the same room so uh
who knows where their relationship might
go thanks for the Super Chat from mother
Nix who says Jace and Helena's dance
scene is a reminder of what could have
happened if that marriage happened yeah
we spoke about that like Jason Helena
were potentially going to get married
rhaenyra proposed that marriage
um and it was lovely to see them dancing
but I do think that Jace was partly
dancing with Helena as a way of sort of
messing with aegon who is Elena's
husband now so I don't know of Jace was
entirely pure in in that dancing scene
um but yeah it's uh it's a sad reminder
of what could have happened
thanks for the Super Chat from Patrick
who says I have a lab report due in two
hours but I can't study without that
viserys Throne Room entry song
constantly what is it called I don't
know you'd have to ask Ramen jawadi uh I
don't know what the what the scenes what
what the musical themes are called
um but uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Jeff who says if they keep Oscar and
Kermit Tully that'd be something yeah we
talked in a previous video about how the
Tully characters in the books are named
Oscar and Kermit and Elmo and Grover who
are Sesame Street characters and and HBO
currently owns the rights to Sesame
Street so no doubt we'll have a
crossover and Elmo will appear to talk
about the importance of friendship and
sharing at some point in the in the show
I don't think you you don't need
permission from Sesame Street to call a
character Elmo or or are the other
lawyers truly that bad that you can't
use the name Elmo without paying a
goddamn stipend to Sesame Street
Incorporated I don't know what the rules
are they should be able to call it
whatever they want
uh thanks for the Super Chat from nikhil
who says why was silencing Diana so
important to Alison well I think partly
you know if Alison allows it to be known
that aegon her preferred claimers to the
throne
um is a sinner who does adultery and you
know sleeps around then that might be
bad for her especially personally given
her whole sort of stance against
rhaenyra it makes Allison a hypocrite if
she lets people find out that aegon
sleeps around and also like children of
aegon if aegon claims the throne his
bastard children could potentially claim
the throne I mean it's like how Catelyn
in Game of Thrones in the books told Rob
like hey like you know bastards like I
mean even you know your bastard
half-brother John if you legitimize him
like they are potential threats to you
um my point is that bastard children of
aegon could be rival claimants to to the
throne
um as Rivals against aegon's own
trueborn children
it's like how in Game of Thrones season
two or three Cersei had Robert
baratheon's bastards murdered there was
that horrible scene where Janos slint
and aladeem went out and slaughtered a
bunch of babies and women in this world
of Bloodlines you don't want Royal
bastards running around mucking up the
succession uh so you know it's it's it's
religious it's political and it's
personal with Alison silencing Diana
there's a lot of levels to that
thanks for the oh yeah it was
interesting that she uh she paid Diana
as well she was like take the moon tea
so that you don't give birth to a baby
and take this money you know sign this
NDA please
um and you know there's plenty to be
said about Alison you know
internalizing the patriarchy and
becoming an enforcer of the system that
has oppressed and restricted her you
know like I think that Allison has
bought into this system like she has
followed the rules with you know uh
having her kids with her leprous with a
leprous husband viserys and it's like
she is so bought into this system that
she wields the system as a weapon
against people who break those rules
that she had followed I think
thanks for the Super Chat from Alchemist
who says in the show John is the prince
that was promised because he saved the
world from Dany that's the show's
subversion
yeah well one of many criticisms of Game
of Thrones season 8 is that they were
not really clear about any of the
prophecy stuff like I don't like like
Melisandre sort of threw her hands up in
season seven and said ah Daenerys and
John they both have roles to play in the
prophecy it's fine and yeah like I think
that's a reasonable interpretation
Alchemist like in the final episode of
Game of Thrones Daenerys was saying hey
let's conquer the world it'll be great
and Jon was like no that won't be great
so she killed so he killed Daenerys so
yeah you could say that you know the
white walk the white walkers weren't the
real threat to the world the real threat
to the world was Daenerys Targaryen and
Jon Snow saved the World by killing
Daenerys I think that's a fair
interpretation it's definitely a downer
it's definitely sad and nihilistic but
yeah I mean that I think that's not an
unreasonable interpretation
thanks for the Super Chat from seruna
who says team Scarab are you referring
to laris's symbol uh Larissa symbol is a
firefly
um this little badge that he has on his
minions according to the HBO official
guide it is meant to be a firefly not a
Scarab
um
I I mean a lot of people were saying
that it's a b because like a b might
pollinate larice's flower and a bee
might you know be busy and buzzing and
making the I don't know there's some
symbolism you could draw but no at least
according to HBO it's a firefly symbol
that larit uses uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Leon who says amond doesn't
want the smoke with Daemon uh thanks for
the Super Chat from Blake who says
viserys hated everyone during that walk
Paddy made me feel the pain in that
moment yeah that's that's the point like
I think viserys felt resentment at
everyone like he he dragged himself up
onto the throne and he's saying like why
do I have to do this why are you
questioning the Valerian succession when
the Valerian succession obviously should
go to my trueborn grandson Luke valerion
um he's an old man he's very sick why
should he have to do all this
um we can yeah I mean maybe viserys
shouldn't have to do all this
um he didn't ask for this responsibility
any more than Rainier asked for this
responsibility you know so it's so funny
that everyone is fighting over the right
to be the ruler when it sucks so bad
being the ruler they are willing to to
put each other through so much to get
something that no one should want
because no one enjoys being King it's
more for people like Otto who get to you
know manipulate the strings of power for
the benefit of their own house that
that's who really benefits from any of
this
thanks for the Super Chat from Zoe who
says wait so were Baylor and Reina split
up between driftmark and Dragonstone
shortly after their mum died yeah sounds
that way so so was it Baylor on
driftmark and Rayna on Dragonstone they
weren't they weren't super clear about
that to me
um I hope we get to see more of Baylor
and Rayna because you know now that they
are betrothed to marry Luke and Jace uh
they're going to be important I would
think
thanks for the Super Chat from Tai who
says did Alison give Diana poison or
Moon tea I I think that she gave Diana
Moon tea I don't think she murdered this
girl I mean why would she if she was
murdering this girl she wouldn't have
needed to say all those things to that
girl about you better not talk like do
these things for me so yeah it was Moon
tea which of course mirrors Melos giving
uh Rainier ramundi after her dalliance
with Daemon thanks for the Super Chat
from cron who says check out what demon
becomes when you move the D to the end
you know what they say about moving the
D to the end oh boy uh yeah Daemon and
amond are very similar names just as
they are quite similar characters it's
all about where you put the D
laughs
thanks for the Super Chat from Zach who
says [ __ ] the greens Prince Daemon is my
future king that that's one of the other
sort of like open questions here right
because like rhaenyra is the heir to the
throne and Daemon is her husband and so
on paper like theoretically Daemon is
going to become the king consort he is
going to become the husband of the queen
but not the ruler himself like the idea
is that rhaenyra is the ruler and Daemon
is just her husband so you know maybe
Rainier might choose to make Daemon her
hand of the king or just some small
Council position or just a military
leader like there's a bunch of different
roles that Daemon could take but I think
that it would not be surprising to
anyone if Daemon started wielding the
power for himself like if Rainier
allowed Daemon to sort of take the reins
of power to some extent like so I think
a lot of people are worried that you
know if Rainier becomes Queen on the
throne Daemon May rule through her and I
don't know you know I don't know if
that's Rainier's intention I think
rhaenyra takes her responsibility
seriously and I think rhaenyra would try
to rule herself but I think that's on a
lot of people's minds is like you know
Rainier are becoming queen means Daemon
being like one step from the throne some
people might worry that Daemon might
murder rhaenyra and seize the throne for
himself I think a lot of people might
consider that I mean Daemon did kill his
previous wife Reya or the the previous
previous wife so
a lot of people worried about Daemon
thanks for this yeah you can't spell
Daemon without the D you got to give the
D otherwise Daemon is not yeah thanks
for the Super Chat from Nicholas uh no I
don't think that Alice and poisoned the
serving girl
um I think that he gave she gave her
Moon tea thanks for the Super Chat from
Raquel who says what did you think about
the symbolism of Jace and Helena dancing
and viserys looking at them dancing I
mean I think viserys was happy to see
the different sides of his family
seemingly getting along and viserys was
thinking yay this is peace but of course
we have seen dancing as a sort of a
symbol for combat like Leno or valerion
uh said to Rainier at their wedding
Feast oh dancing is a lot like combat uh
dancing is like fighting dancing is like
killing so you could also say that at
the same time that this you know Helena
J stance is really cute and lovely it
also could foreshadow violence and of
course there there is is a conflict in
The Game of Thrones books called the
dance of the Dragons
um which you know dance as a euphemism
for war so you can see the dancing in a
few different ways I guess dancing can
also be seen as like a sexual thing like
dancing as a sort of a mating dance or
like flirtation or whatever so you know
dancing is dancing is joy and it's sex
and it's combat and it's killing and
it's war and it's it's all of those
things
thanks for the Super Chat from Smith who
says Arya is Azor ahai her dagger the
catsport dagger is lightbringer Night's
King is Nissan Theory confirmed yeah so
the prophecy uh I mean some of the
Legends around the prophecy you
mentioned Nissan who is like the
sacrifice victim who Azor ahai kills in
order to forge the blade lightbringer
um and so maybe the night King was the
sacrifice who was was killed for the
greater good and now that the night King
was killed that allows for the birth of
a new kingdom sure we can interpret it
like that why not thanks for the Super
Chat from Gunner who says that this
episode felt like the Calm before the
storm yeah I mean I enjoyed how they had
literal Thunder in the background in the
weirwood and then there was rain when
um rain when viserys died so that there
certainly is the storm approaching uh
Irvin says is have they ever said the
word black in the show yeah so in the
books Alison's side is called the greens
and Rainier's side is called the blacks
and in the show they have referred to
Alison's side as the greens rhaenyra
says that but they've never talked about
the blacks and I do wonder if they might
avoid saying the blacks in the show
because they have made the Valeri on the
valerion's dark-skinned and they don't
want people being confused by what is
meant by the blacks because in the books
that just refers to rhaenyra's side
whereas people might think it's
referring to skin color I think it would
be lame if they like avoided saying the
blacks because that like is one of the
central terms for the political
situation in the books some people have
said well maybe they'll change it to
like the greens and the Reds like
because the Targaryen colors are black
and red
so instead of black you could just as
equally say red I guess that would make
sense
um but I think one of the episodes this
season is called the black queen uh so
that suggests that they might use the
blacks thing so yeah I idea we'll see
how it goes I'm sure the live chat will
be really
um really mature about this issue thanks
for the Super Chat from non dormiant who
says team crab uh yeah celtagas all the
way I I want to believe that the crab
feeder is a secret celtica thanks for
the Super Chat from Dominique who says
amond wouldn't be as cool without the
eye patch R.I.P euron Greyjoy yeah so
year on Greyjoy is one of the coolest
and scariest characters in the books
he's a sorcerer and uh and a pirate king
and a and a hallucinogenic drug user and
a kin Slayer and a god Slayer and a
lovecraftian absolute Beast of a of a
man and uh in the TV show they made him
into this goofy ass Pirates of the
Caribbean Disney pirate who uh did not
did not scare anyone and did not even
have an eye patch what a travesty
thanks for the Super Chat from Nathan
Elite Natalie who says do you think
viserys regrets naming his daughter as
air I mean even in episode 1 when
viseras first made Rainier air he was
telling her like this is not a gift like
he was telling her this is a heavy
burden this is a tough responsibility I
do not put this on you lightly so from
the very beginning viserys had some
concerns and he knew this would be hard
for rain era
um and I think you know as the throne
and the responsibility of power has
destroyed uh viserys's body and mind you
know like the psychological and
emotional weight of the throne
destroying him symbolically if not
literally uh I think that he only has
more concerns and doubts about about
what he's passing on to his daughter
um so yeah I think there's probably an
element of regret there but you know he
did reaffirm his support for an era
um like he never he never changed his
mind I mean like I thought it's
interesting that in the books at least
when viserys told rhaenyra hey you're
going to marry Lenor
um and in the books Rainier did not want
to marry lane or like she was very
opposed to it
um partly because she knew that lane all
was gay and she didn't want a husband
who wasn't attracted to her and viserys
in the books said okay Rainier if you
don't marry Lenor I'll disinherit you
and so that was the one thing that made
Rainier ago okay fine I'll marry Elena
so like in the books viserys did like
consider disinheriting rhaenyra whereas
they didn't do that in a hot day to my
knowledge so viserys was like pretty
pretty consistent in his support of
rhaenyra and the showrunners have said
that that is connected to viserys's love
for Emma his first wife so uh yeah I
think the viserys despite his fears
despite the weight that he was putting
on his daughter he um
he didn't back down because he didn't
stop loving Emma which I think is a
really beautiful angle on viserys's
character
thanks for the Super Chat from the real
Neil accept no substitute who says amond
is the scariest person that strong toast
was the highlight of the episode for me
yeah aemond insulted Jason Luke by
calling them strong and it is like a
wonderful Checkmate because you know
obviously
by calling Jace and Luke strong amond is
calling Jace and Luke bastards because
Jace and Luke are not the sons of lane
or valerion they are actually the
bastard sons of Harwin strong and so
Jace and Luke get angry and aimond is
like oh why are you angry it's only a
compliment to say that you're so strong
and muscular uh so you know like Jason
Luke can only get angry if they sort of
admit that like yeah like how and strong
is our actual father or you know
allegedly
um so it is a fun way to be like passive
aggressive and to like call them
bastards without calling them bastards I
I do really like how fundamentally you
know like yes you know 87 of you in that
poll agreed that rhaenyra and her family
are the good guys but rhaenyra and her
family are the Liars who are who who
have you know bastard children and are
saying that they're not bastards and
it's it's it it's cool how you know it
makes a side with the Liars which sort
of puts us in a difficult position
morally and legalistically because this
whole monarchy relies on you know the
honest application of these inheritance
laws just like vemond was saying you
know like like it's kind of hard to
disagree with Raymond when he's saying
that the truth is obvious and yet
they're like gaslighting vamond and
gaslighting Allison and making us
side with the Liars it's fun it's fun
uh Keith says how did he get his eye cut
out
uh well aemond got his eye slashed out
by
um got his eye slashed out by
Luke you're how did how did euron
Greyjoy lose his eye
do the books say how euron Greyjoy lost
his I don't
am I am I crazy or does the books not
say how euron lost his eye I wonder he
didn't lose his eye he hasn't lost his
eye he just has like a black eye
underneath like he's got two eyes he's
got his smiling eye and then he's got
his like black scary eye because it's
just like you know Sailors and Pirates
they wear an eye patch so that they can
um so they can like go from below decks
to above decks without losing their
night vision or whatever the crap right
yeah yeah euron has two eyes but I think
there is like we've never seen what's
underneath his eye patch really and
Theon has this dream where he like see
yeah the blood eye and it's like and and
he's and Theon is like deathly afraid of
like the black eye underneath the eye
patch and there's all this stuff about
like euron may have you know Green Seer
sight he may have been a student of
bloodraven so it's like the third eye
the Magic Eye the dark eye the evil eye
all sorts of wonderful scary magical uh
symbolism going on
so uh so yeah there's a really um metal
character
called uh Crow food umber in the books
and Crow fruit Amber uh lost an eye
because like I think he got like he got
like wounded in a battle and um while he
was lying there like half dead a raven
came and ate his eye out of his socket
and then he like killed the Raven or
something and now Crow food Amber wears
a chunk of dragon glass in his eye
socket which is just so cool and metal
and ridiculous and it's such a shame
that we didn't get that sort of fun
stuff in the show
thanks for the Super Chat from what who
says I wish they did more practical
makeup for viserys's face rot it's
supposed to be unsettling but it looks a
bit fake yeah I agree with that like I
think that viserys is like rotted face
with the missing eye and the hole in his
in his cheek sometimes it looked good
sometimes it looked a bit you know fake
um what I did like about vamon's messed
about viserys's messed up face was the
sound of his breath going through his
cheek hole like if you listen there's
this weird gross sort of like gasping
breathing sound which I think was meant
to be the air going through the hole in
viserys's face and it like maybe the the
hole didn't look good all the time but
the sound of it I thought was very
unsettling and very effective personally
um that was really intense and it's
reminiscent of um it's reminiscent of
bloody
buddy buddy who am I thinking of the
Hound sandor Clegane Sanuk again also
has
um a lot of missing face bits like in
the show it's just like oh we'll just
put some just put some makeup on his
cheek but in the books he's he's it's
like raw burned [ __ ] up flesh it's
like real gnarly sandor's wounds in um
in the books like I think he's got like
a hole in his cheek and everything in
the books so um sort of reminds me of
that
anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Smythe who says amond is great looks a
lot like David Bowie
look I would love to see this guy built
out
um built out some Bowie but uh
maybe we'll have to wait for season two
thanks for the Super Chat from viserys
who says that viserys the Super Chat
from Ricky who says that viserys gazes
up at the iron throne with such contempt
his reluctant acceptance of the heavy
duty he was given yeah I I think that
that sequence was so powerful in showing
viserys's
relationship with power and relationship
with politics and like how it was just
this insurmountable object for him like
he just could not handle this this
terrible burden and yeah yeah I guess
resent was part of it it's like he'd why
do I have to do this why does anyone
have to do this and I mean and of course
part of the answer is well the bloody
council at harrenhal is why he has to do
this because he was chosen by the Lords
of the realm to rule as king because the
realm did not accept rhaenys or lanor
um it was partly
it that decision is the reason why
viserys has to drag himself up these
steps all these years later so I you
know I I think it's an indictment of the
system and of the Lords and partly of
you know the patriarchy that refuses to
accept a woman and prefers a man viserys
I mean you know in the books it was more
about rainy's son lanor versus viserys
at the council at Aaron Hall but in the
show they framed it more about rhaenys
versus viserys and the realm wanting a
man not not the female rainies thanks
for the Super Chat from significant ice
who says do you think HBO plans on
fixing the prince that was promised
Prophecy in the snow sequel somehow yeah
so there is
it has been reported including by George
Martin uh that there is a Jon Snow TV
show in early development and you know
when something's in early development it
it may or may not happen but apparently
kit Harrington's excited and George
Martin's excited so maybe they're going
to make more Jon Snow snuff Jon Snow's
stuff
I I don't I don't love the idea but if
George Martin thinks it's a good idea
then maybe it is
um I think it would be very weird to
make a sequel to Game of Thrones season
eight I think it would have to be a very
different kind of show I I don't think
going back on the prince that was
promised so I mean they could bring back
the White Walkers and they could make
Jon defeat the White Walkers and then
that sort of retroactively makes the
prince that was promised stuff make more
sense but I don't know I don't know I
don't want it thanks for the Super Chat
from MZ Kim who says the Artistry in
this show is Top Notch the costumes sets
props all amazing really happy this is
better than the last few seasons of got
the costuming especially I agree yeah
yeah the um the costuming like in Game
of Thrones season 8 was like mostly just
black leather outfits whereas here
there's so much character in The Outfits
like I mean Alison definitely had one of
the more notable costumes in this
episode The Chain the restraint the
faith of the seven symbol uh the sort of
like proud shoulders I thought that
aemon's outfit also had a sort of a
dragony aspect to it like aemond had
these sort of wing-like shoulders
because I think that aemond is proud of
his connection to uh Vega the greatest
dragon in the world
um yeah look at these like proud
prominent wing-like shoulders that
aemond has so yeah I think that the
costumes tell us a lot about the
characters that was really fun
thanks for the Super Chat from rackney
who says I can't help but like amond
he's clever and seems to understand what
it's going to come next aemond
definitely seems more aware than like
aegon and Helena are like I mean like
Helena sees the future but doesn't quite
seem to consciously comprehend what it
all means she's sort of off with the
fairies and aegon is just either in his
wine or in his in his Bitties um so he's
not really paying much attention amond
is the guy who's like
I I want to like be a part of this I
want conflict I want to get revenge like
yeah I I think I agree with that and you
know he his intentions do not seem great
thanks for the Super Chat from Dylan uh
we don't want to do any spoilers
um but there are interesting
possibilities with the valerions thanks
for the super chats from Brian who says
I don't like the high Towers so I don't
like the greens but the blacks made many
mistakes before the war even started I
just feel bad for the kids involved
especially the strong boys yeah I feel
Eternal Sympathy for the children
dragged into the wars of their parents
um I think that Rainier is mistake in
hooking up with Harwin strong is like
the original sin in this show like if
Rainier just hooked up with someone who
looked like Lenor like a valerion cousin
or just someone on driftmark or just
someone who looked vaguely like Lenor
like even just like someone with
Valyrian hair like there were lots of
people in like lease and like the east
system and on Dragonstone there are lots
of people on Dragonstone who have
Valyrian features
and if rhaenyra had her bastard children
with one of those people so that her
children looked plausibly like Lena's
children this whole conflict may never
have happened so I think rhaenyra does
have a huge amount of culpability for
this entire conflict
thanks for this super chat from
ludicrous who says the show is amazing
but I don't like how straight evil the
greens are which the creators said that
they would try to correct from the books
aegon is a rapist amond is amond and
Otto and Alison are self-serving yeah I
mean that's something that people say
about the books as well like I think
they are being faithful to the books in
making the greens look more dickish than
the blacks I mean we'll see how it
continues I think that you know last
episode in particular I think they did a
lot to sort of give us an insight into
Allison's position and to see why she
feels the way she does how she feels
trapped how she feels resentful but I
mean even Alison's actor herself Olivia
Cook says that like she can't defend all
of Alison's actions so yeah I mean I
agree with you that the greens generally
seem more villainous
um Raphael says why does aegon look
younger than amond yeah a lot of people
complaining that aemond looks old maybe
he's just aged before his time as a
result result of pure anger
losing his eye you know riding Vega I
mean it's probably not good for your
skin care regime to be riding Vega all
the time I mean all those seagulls that
Amanda took to the face it's gonna It's
Gonna Give You crow's feet before you
know it thanks for the Super Chat from
boy who says wandering where the club
foot was in all this seems like a lot of
fun for him to be missing out on uh yeah
that's that's a good point uh larus
would have been interested in all of
these goings on I mean I wonder if Laris
is interest is listening from beneath
the floorboards you know the beasts
beneath the boards and we did see a
mouse or a rat uh on on the Valyrian
model City in viserys's room so that you
know it seems like they are connecting
the the mice to Laris and his spying so
I think it's possible that Laris has
some presence in this episode even if
it's not directly on screen
um and boy says what happened to our
good friend Gladys yeah there is a
wonderful Game of Thrones YouTube
channel called glidus that you should
all go and subscribe to and glidus has
been having a um having a bit of a time
with the weekly upload schedule with
House of the Dragon I think but I think
that schedules I mean time is an
illusion and YouTube uploads schedules
doubly so so uh I think there'll be more
gliders blistake videos soon
um if not in a strictly weekly sequence
I think there will be more so go and
subscribe to gliders thanks for the
Super Chat from Dylan who says who
inherits viserys's Warhammer set yeah I
mean maybe that's maybe that's the deal
maybe viserys is like okay like rhaenyra
gets the throne and Alison gets my
um my necrom under set my my my towel
tyranid carnifex uh
and my adeptice Aurora test and
mechanicus they get my toys and outrania
against the throne which is an equally
valuable prize
thanks for the Super Chat from Tackett
who says pass on the snow show just give
me dunk and egg yeah there is also talk
of a dunk and egg uh TV show in early
development and I would be pretty Keen
for that but as I've said before the
Duncan Egg book series is not finished
and I I want the books to be finished
before they start making the Duncan egg
show because there is some wonderful
dark powerful stuff foreshadowed to
happen
um
towards the end of Duncan Egg and I want
to read that on paper before I see it on
screen but uh we're gonna have to uh get
some more books from the fat man before
that happens
whose plan the fat man's plan that
changes with every Moon that there is a
wonderful fourth wall breaking moment in
um book five when I think George is
talking about himself when he writes
about illyrio's plans changing just as
George's Publications plans have
publication plans have changed oh George
we love you thanks for the Super Chat uh
who says why did amond look like he'd
fallen in love when Daemon sliced off
vemon's head Jesus Christ amond Daemon
vemond I've got to enunciate uh and the
looks they gave each other at Dino was
so flirty look Daemon is
um uh bisexual
sort of canonically I think it's I think
it's uh I think it's questionable Canon
but there's there's some bisexual vibes
from Daemon in pentos uh maybe maybe
Daemon and Amon don't hate each other
maybe they just really need a snog who
knows
um I think that aemond might have been
happy when vamon died because amond is
Keen for violence I think amond is very
clearly he doesn't want peace he wants
um Revenge he wants violence he wants to
prove himself I mean much like Daemon
himself
like I think that Daemon looks at amond
and sees it's like looking in the mirror
it's like seeing a younger version of
himself I think amond now is like what
Daemon used to be like I get the sense
that aemon that Daemon has matured a bit
and he has become a bit more peaceful
because he's a dad now he's a dad to
Baylor and Raina he's a dad to aegon and
viserys
um I think that Daemon has mellowed a
bit I mean he's still very happy to cut
off a dude's head in the middle of a
conversation uh but that's still
relatively Chill by his standards
there's a great scene where Jaime
Lannister talks to Loris Tyrell in the
books and Jaime looks at lorus and goes
wow this impetuous rude arrogant twerp
is me
this this rambunctious talented teenager
is just like what I was like when I was
his age and I think that Daemon might
see amond in a similar way
you know this this was me when I was a
when I was full of spunk and Bluster
thanks for the Super Chat from William
who says so much strength in such a weak
and decaying body yeah everyone I think
has been moved by viserys's performance
here that mask is so creepy as well
what's with that like line going down
the mask is that meant to be like it
looks it looks a little bit like a river
of tears from his eye or like a river of
blood like it's a very creepy design
my goodness
thanks for the Super Chat from Edo who
says highly enjoying all the discussions
you bring for us thank you for making
this TV watching experience a real treat
thanks Edo glad you're enjoying
William said hoping for demon and amond
to have dialogue yeah I would like to
see that too there are so many
characters in this show they have to be
very selective about you know who
actually gets scenes together
um it's a real juggle it I mean right
like it is shocking how well this show
has gone so far honestly I was not
expecting this show to be this good it's
not easy because like they do have a
skeleton of the story in Fire and Blood
but there's very little detail to draw
on
there's a lot of different ways it could
have gone there's a lot of different
ways this show could have been a
catastrophe honestly and I think they've
done a surprisingly good job
thanks for the Super Chat from jarek who
says any thoughts on how the viserys in
Game of Thrones had a golden face at the
end of his life as well Ah that's an
interesting point jarek uh because yeah
viserys Targaryen in uh the original
Game of Thrones show not in House of the
Dragon was the brother of uh Daenerys
Targaryen and he died under a Golden
Crown Khal Drogo poured molten gold on
Dewey's face so just like viserys has a
golden mask uh for Sarah says a golden
mask now yeah that's a cool point I
wonder if that was deliberate probably
um and you know I guess like in some
symbolic sense you know that golden mask
represents how you know power is killing
viserys you know like his
responsibilities and his stress uh is
what has caused his physical
deterioration in some sense and uh in
the same way it's this it's viserys
targaryens dany's Brothers
um you know sort of desire and ambition
and you know wanting power is what leads
to him dying with his face covered by
gold so yeah I think that's uh that's a
cool parallel
thanks for the Super Chat from Tim who
says rhaenyra said Seven Kingdoms a lot
but Dawn isn't in the fold yet is it
yeah so the whole Seven Kingdoms thing
um is an anachronism
um there aren't currently Seven Kingdoms
but I think there were Seven Kingdoms
when aegon the Conqueror took over
Westeros because at the time
um the iron islands and the riverlands
were one Kingdom like the iron the
ironborn conquered the riverlands under
Haron [ __ ] he was the guy who built
harrenhal
um and also there's like the crown lands
which may or may not count as its own
kingdom which is just the region around
King's Landing because yeah but yeah
like Dawn is currently not in the Seven
Kingdoms so like depending how you count
it there's as many as like nine kingdoms
with like the North and the iron islands
and the veil and the riverlands and the
Westlands and the crown lands and the
stormlands and the rage and Dawn
um so there's a few ways to count it but
I think that when aegon conquered
Westeros there were Seven Kingdoms and
they called it Seven Kingdoms but I mean
also like they introduced viserys this
episode as the king of the first man in
the candles and the Rhino and the Rhino
are an ethnic group in Dawn so it's
funny that the targaryens are claiming
authority over Dawn when they don't
actually rule Dawn and Dawn has not
submitted to them so
I mean a bit like in real history
there's anachronisms the names don't
necessarily make sense anymore and you
know that's that's what oh my God what
the [ __ ] is that
um Jesus Christ uh and anyway thanks for
the question
thanks for the question from Jo who says
the most annoying part about the
prophecy is that there is no way viserys
wouldn't have told all of the family
about the prophecy as a means to get
them to reconcile I mean let's be honest
Jo if you went to Thanksgiving dinner
with your family and then your father
viserys said hey guys you need to stop
fighting because there are these icy
Frosty zombies who are gonna come from
the distant North they're going to come
down from Canada and they're going to
March on Washington with a bunch of
walking dead so therefore you need to
marry your cousin like would you take
that seriously I mean people don't
believe in the white walkers I mean I
guess the targaryens might be a little
more amenable to the White Walker thing
seeing as the targaryens you know ride
dragons and you know they are magical
and they do sort of believe
um in such things but yeah like I don't
know if people would listen to the whole
prophecy thing necessarily
um but you know I generally I agree like
I think that if they're taking the White
Walker thing seriously they should be
telling everybody about it and I think
that could be a way of strengthening the
Targaryen like sort of political
cultural claim to the throne like if
they said hey this is not just about
Targaryen power this is about divine
right this is about you know the
targaryens will protect the world from
the White Walkers and regardless of
whether that's true it might be a way to
like secure more political support for
themselves you know
um MF says that viserys's left arm grows
back at the 41 minute Mark does it they
have made a a couple of um CGI mistakes
uh viserys's left arm is meant to be
missing
um but uh apparently we see it at some
point do we
that would not Shock Me thanks for the
Super Chat from winifree iPhone 4 who
says really liked hearing elements of
the king's arrival theme from Game of
Thrones during viserys's dramatic
entrance yeah I mean that could be a
sort of an ironic
um use of the music you know playing a
song of strength while showing viserys's
physical weakness
uh we've been streaming for two hours so
we're going to wrap this up pretty
shortly
um I'm going to answer as many super
chats as I can quickly and then I think
we'll move on to a brief look at the
preview of The Next Episode uh we'll
we'll warn you if if you want to avoid
that before we do it uh but let's do a
little lightning round darker Zazzle
says what was your reaction when Daemon
sliced vemon's head yeah it was fun and
surprising uh because it's different to
the books
um I guess yeah I guess I can say what
happened in the books in the books
um
oh well maybe they'll do it later I
won't say
um but yeah I liked how they showed that
Valyrian steel really is sharp and
special as well uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Jess who says aegon and
viserys who are the baby children of
rhaenyra and Daemon it was fun to see
them uh thanks for the Super Chat from
zevi who rightfully points out an issue
thanks for the Super Chat from Musa who
says the very conspicuous to second
appearance of Lord Caswell yeah so we we
did briefly see Lord Caswell greeting
rhaenyra and Daemon outside the red keep
um and Lord Caswell we saw in episode
six I think when Caswell was uh ah let
me be the first to congratulate you
radio on you having a baby good work
um so Lord Caswell is a lord in the
reach and uh it looks like he's
positioning himself as an ally to
Rainier which might be useful later on
thanks for the Super Chat from Bill who
says did you notice crisp and Cole
was swinging a steel Morning Star at
amond yeah seems like a very dangerous
way to train like you know they they
sometimes wear
um they sometimes use blunted swords for
training and they sometimes wear like
lots of padded armor and lots of armor
but uh yeah aemond and Kristen were
pretty YOLO just swinging live steel at
each other and I don't know maybe that's
just a more effective way to train but
uh yeah there's there's an element of
danger there I know that the Christian
actor Fabian Frankel was saying that uh
it's extremely hard to swing a Morning
Star around without hitting yourself in
the balls so um let's all send our best
wishes to Fabian Frankel's testicles uh
clearbright says I appreciate your
channel and all the Insight it affords
uh also I can't wait for Daemon and
amond to dance I hope they have a boogie
thank you Shino kyuko who says viserys
saying no more might have been him
remembering Emma telling him no more
kids before her death yeah I think
that's a good point
because in the conversation in the bath
with Emma and viserys Emma was saying
this is the last child I will bear for
you I don't think she said no more but
she said you know there will be no more
children from me which was right in more
ways than she knew um so yeah maybe
that's what viserys was thinking thanks
for the Super Chat from the circuit who
says Alison feeling bad for the servant
girl and showing more compassion to her
than to her own son yeah yeah I mean I
think that Alison was partly like
threatening this girl and manipulating
her by sort of pretending to be tender
but also threatening her not to talk
about aegon getting her pregnant like I
thought this was quite you know I
thought that this hand on the back of
Diana's head was very sort of possessive
um on her head but but yeah like it was
so harsh the way that Alison like
slapped aegon and said you are no son of
mine which is a pretty [ __ ] heavy
thing to say to your kid
um and as reminiscent of Thailand
because Tywin told Tyrion you are no son
of mine uh in the in the books at least
I think in the show he might have said
you are not my son whatever um but yeah
that was real rough elephant is not
affectionate to her kids Alison does not
have a lot of
um yeah I mean you know and Allison had
their kids very young and you know the
actor talked about them being almost
more like siblings than like children
and Alison's actor talked about Alison
feeling jealous of rhaenyra being such a
good mother it's a whole thing thanks
for the Super Chat from Elm who says
when do you believe we will go beyond
the wall
uh The Way episode 8 ends I'm under the
impression we might get a glimpse of
what Terror lies Beyond yeah I mean they
might not like there's nothing in the
books about white walkers
um in Fire and Blood nothing direct
anyway but uh without spoiling anything
yeah there are opportunities to do a bit
of that so who knows like they are
talking a lot about the prophecy so
maybe they will introduce a little bit
of Whitey walkie goodness thanks for the
donation from Zach who says Daemon is
the definition of [ __ ] around find out
Schwab says Damon's dong
okay you thought we were literally
talking about daemon's penis uh Ian says
no more was referring to being tested as
talked about with Lionel strong this
episode was his Crucible and viserys
died thinking he United the realm
yeah there was that conversation with
Lionel where viserys was like will I be
remembered as a good King did I do the
right thing and I think that right at
the very end he decided yeah I'm gonna
do the right thing and he died thinking
that he had succeeded but little does he
know
um right as soon as he left the table
his grandsons started attacking each
other so I mean at least he got to die
relatively happy but um he was mistaken
if he thinks that he made peace uh
Vaughn uh yeah we talked about Alison
you know saying you're no son of mine
just like Tywin it's a really heavy
cruel thing to say to your child like I
mean aegon is you know biologically the
son of Alison and viserys but I think
that Alison feels a lot of frustration
with aegon because he you know keeps on
having sex with people when he shouldn't
and he doesn't take his responsibilities
seriously and so Alison expresses that
frustration with a lot of antagonism
which is really sad
uh Jesus says I'm team rhaenyra but I
sympathize with Alison she knows her
kids are bad but she just sort of Daemon
kill vemond for speaking truth who's
next yeah I think that I think that
Rainier probably is more sympathetic but
I think that um we can definitely
sympathize with both sides Mick says
fireflies any connection to dragon fire
yeah that's that's a good uh that's a
good comparison because you know Laura's
using the Firefly as his symbol it's
like saying that well you know I'm not a
dragon I'm not big and powerful and
tough and controlling a great weapon of
War I don't have a nuke on wings but I
can still wield fire I can still wield
fire through manipulation and with my
Firefly people so you know yeah like
that's kind of cool that's like well I'm
not as tough as you targaryens but I've
still got my own fire and I can still
wield destruction yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Tay who
says Alison is being willfully ignorant
she probably knows the prophecy from
being with viserys plus she knows aegon
would be a terrible King I I don't think
that Allison knows about the prophecy
like if she knew about the prophecy I
think she would have reacted differently
to viserys's Last Words
um and I think that viserys was pretty
clear about like we only tell the heir
to the throne about the prophecy but
yeah I think Tay is being I think sorry
I think Alison is sort of willfully
misinterpreting viserys's last words and
choosing to think that it's about aegon
but I mean you know like Alison was just
saying rhaenyra you're going to be a
great Queen and we should be friends
again and I and I think that Alison does
mean it
um when she says that so I don't think
that in this moment Alison is like 100
like [ __ ] Rainier I'm gonna support
aegon
um I think that there will be further
developments
thanks for the Super Chat from Claire
who says Rainier has five children now
she is certainly much luckier than her
mother yet rhaenyra has five children
now Jace and Luke and Joff with uh
Harwin and viserys and aegon with Daemon
and rhaenyra is pregnant again they
didn't make a big deal of it but but
rhaenyra is currently pregnant you can
see that she's a bit pregnant so um so
maybe she'll have six children soon
thanks for the Super Chat from Mike and
yeah I mean as you say like we saw a lot
about the dangers of pregnancy with Emma
and with Lena so I I think that we can
look forward to more horrifying
childbirths as the story continues
thanks for the Super Chat from Mike who
said they expected a big Naval Dragon
Battle with vemond alas vemond did not
get to do much but um he's got family
thanks Heather thanks orc who says we're
all forgetting that daemon's children
can't be king unless he gets those
strong kids out of the way so of course
he encourages vemond to call them
bastards yeah so when vemond called Jace
and Luke bastards yeah Daemon was sort
of egging him on I think Daemon was
egging him on because he wanted to kill
vemond and remove the threat to
rhaenyra's claim but yeah like Daemon is
a not a great guy and he's murdered
people before
um for you know his own political
freedoms so yeah like it would not be
crazy to suspect that what if Daemon
killed rhaenyra's Sons so that his own
sons aegon and viserys could claim the
throne instead I think that's a
reasonable suspicion I mean would Daemon
do something so horrible against
rhaenyra who he loves or seems to love
who knows but things may evolve
multi-guy says couldn't Targaryen
bastards claim dragons I could see how
that might cause issues that is an
extremely good question that may be
relevant later on I'm pretty sure
dragons look I'll say this I don't think
dragons care if your parents were
married I don't I don't think dragons
are quite that legalistic so uh yeah
that's a relevant question
Bose says lots of references to the
prince that was promised do you think
that the snow show might fulfill the
prophecy uh yeah maybe Val the wildling
will play the role of the night's Queen
I think it would be weird if the Jon
Snow sequel show talks about the
prophecy much but um we'll see uh
mcgreeney pants says Alison killed Diana
with poison I don't think it was poison
I mean she did ask about Diana later so
maybe it was poison but my
interpretation was that it's Moon tea
we'll go back and have a look at that
later uh Mark says good day thank you
Mark G1 says rhaenyra isn't aware of
lenor's survival
yeah I mean that's a good point like
like rhaenyra said to rhaenys hey like I
didn't murder your son lanor
um but what Rainier could have said is
uh hey rainey's not only did I not
murder your son Lena but your son Lenor
wasn't murdered at all and is alive in
the East or in a row boat at least
um she could have said that but she
didn't
and I guess the reason why Rainier
didn't tell rhaenys that her son is
alive is that
then rhaenys would probably want to
reunite with her son and would probably
find her son and bring her son back and
then all of a sudden rhaenyra would have
two husbands Leno and Daemon and that
would be embarrassing for everyone so um
so yeah I guess she she couldn't tell
rainey's the truth and I wonder if
rainy's might ever find out you know
what if what if Raines finds out that
lane or was alive when Lenor dies for
real maybe Lena will die in the East and
then rainy will find out that oh my God
my son was alive all these years that
would be crazy that would be dark
um
yeah
thanks
you know there's people arguing in the
chat about whether Allison murdered
Diana the serving girl I I don't think
she did but we'll we'll go back and have
a look at it later
thanks for the Super Chat from Mason who
says Rainier with viserys was on her
good side yeah yeah I I think that
viserys's like rotted face side was on
the green side which you know does sort
of cast The Greens as as villains like
the mask side the rotten side is
Alison's side whereas the healthy side
is Rainier's side so they are sending us
signals that like Rainier's side are the
good side thank you Steve thank you
elhan who says did Helena already have
amon's children's Helena is married to
aegon
um and
at least in this point in the book uh
they do have kids maybe that will
um maybe we'll see that soon on the show
uh thanks Ashley who also complains
about amond uh well apparently all right
amon's actor is only 20. so for all the
people complaining that he looks old
um I think that's just
um just uh poor skincare is actually
only 20 apparently uh Glock was looking
for Laris Nick says aegon looks younger
than the previous actor yeah I kind of I
kind of agree with that like the new
aegon actor doesn't look much older than
the uh previous aegon actor Michael says
that why doesn't Helena why doesn't
viserys thinks it thinks it why doesn't
viserys think that why doesn't viserys
think it's weird that Helena is talking
prophecies almost like she's being
walked into there's a fun idea maybe
Helena is actually being walked into by
bloodraven through time and space who is
trying to prevent the dance and prevent
the downfall of his ancestors that's a
fun idea
um and yeah you would think that viserys
would be more interested in Helena's
prophecies since viserys is or at least
was obsessed with prophecies himself
like viserys was going on about ooh
Targaryen dreamers are so rare and so
special and his own daughter is a
Targaryen dreamer and yet he doesn't
ever have a conversation with her that
we've seen so I think viserys is like
not a great dad not very attentive to
his children with Alison
I mean to be fair his body parts are are
falling off day by day so he's a bit
distracted but um yeah it's sad that
viserys isn't a closer father uh
angleboard says viserys's last means no
more
viserys's last words no more mean no
more prophecies
uh maybe Brian says I loved the version
of the king's arrival song played when
viserys comes in almost got an ironic
vibe to it Dominique says that amond
wouldn't be as cool without the eye
patch I completely agree mother Nix says
the episode was very Shakespearean
viserys let go of Life at the end
because the family stuff was resolved
yeah it's almost like a ghost can
finally you know go to the afterlife
after the ghost's unfinished business is
done like viserys was like already dead
in so many ways you know like physically
it was like he was a ghost already you
know but he could only leave and move on
to the next life after he finished his
business and was satisfied that his
family was at peace and of course he was
uh completely wrong
Musa hopes that amond might have a
sapphire underneath his eye patch fig
says I love amond
and the strong insult was great thank
you Darius for the shout out thank you
vasoon who says Rainier said that Daemon
would help assure her claim to the
throne she didn't mean by cutting people
in half
oh yeah no yeah well yeah that's true
like like I think that rhaenyra marrying
Daemon you know she wants strength in
order to claim the throne and
and it's not just about you know
daemon's claim as viserys's brother and
it's not just about you know political
laws and so on it's also about the fact
that everyone knows that Daemon is a
stone cold killer with a cool ass
squeaky dragon and you don't want to
[ __ ] with him he's got dark sister he's
a badass and he's not afraid of nothing
so yeah that's definitely part of why
um rhaenyra married him and he provides
strength to her
Inquisitor says every Faith seems to
have some truth except for the seven
yeah I mean that that's a whole big can
of worms but like you know the religion
of the old gods has the very very real
power of skin changing and walking and
the children of the forest and the magic
of the Drowned God
resuscitates people or it seems to have
like some power that like euron is
tapping into well I don't know the John
goddess may be [ __ ] as well
um but there's lots of different
religions and the faith of the seven
seems to be the least powerful I mean
relore has those like shadow assassin
babies that Melisandre births so there
is real magic behind some of the
religions but the faith of the seven
doesn't have any real religious Miracles
that we can point to so I think that the
faith of the seven is more the sort of
sanitized institutional religion as
opposed to the real raw powerful magical
religion
I think that's a fair point thanks for
the Super Chat from AV who says that
rhaenyra in episode 3 killed abort ahai
the pig that was promised yes uh
bloodraven was warging the pig of course
and was going to use it to um become the
pig King I mean I mean maybe the the
pink dread was the child of the boar
that rhaenyra killed and therefore the
pink dread is Azora high so don't worry
AV Motas says that rhaenyra doesn't seem
to know that Lenor is alive I think that
rhaenyra does know that Leonor is alive
she just couldn't tell rhaenys that
lanor is alive or else rhaenys would go
and find Lenor and then Rainey Rainier
would have two husbands
um I think that Helena's comment about
what's under the floorboards could refer
to spies in the red keep it could refer
to the lurking danger beneath the you
know beneath appearances and it also
could refer to something that's going to
happen later on in the story Frank says
how old is viserys
um I'm sure someone in the chat can do
the math uh I don't know off the top of
my head how old he is I mean I might
have I might have it written down
um I think that he is all right I think
he's 51.
I think that King viserys is 51 or 52
years old at this point in the books at
least they I think they changed the ages
in the show so maybe that's no longer
true but at least in the books I think
viserys is about 50.
thanks for the Super Chat from veeamon's
tongue who says it's cruel to let rainys
think that Lenor is dead I agree I I
would love to see Rainier tell rhaenys
the truth and I think that their
discussion about lane or here
um might sort of foreshadow that so yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Neymar
who says the who says does rhaenys raise
daemon's daughters yeah I think that
Baylor is on drift Mark with rhaenys
while Rayna is on Dragonstone with
rhaenyra and Daemon I think that's a
situation maybe it's the other way
around it's hard to keep track of the
twins but I hope we'll see more of raila
Rayna and Baylor later Rayna and Baylor
later seggy says I appreciate that they
aged up aegon before showing us his
Gooch yeah well look it's got to be the
gooch has to be of age Joshua says
according to the logic of the show the
greens are correct but in my heart I
side with the guillotine the guillotine
oh my God Joshua gingerbread says Helena
wearing gold this episode instead of
green do you think that's foreshadowing
or relevant yeah well I mean maybe she
was wearing a cheese yellow dress GE
says that aemond is Daemon 2.0
thanks for the Super Chat from Holmes
brothers who says that Alison is more
and more corrupt in her increasing
belief of the servant I mean Alison
would not be the first person to use
religion to see to seem all high and
mighty and virtuous when in actual fact
the religion is a is a false cloak
disguising uh sin I mean it's like
Rainier told Alison in the previous
episode like your righteousness is a
cloak it's a disguise and it's it's an
excuse and I think that the Newfound
religion that Alison is wielding is uh
perhaps another cloak
thanks for the Super Chat from Nicholas
who says I'd love to see George Martin
appearing on Hot D just like Stan Lee on
Marvel movies I mean I would prefer he
stays home in New Mexico riding wins but
I mean you know he did appear in the
Game of Thrones original pilot that got
re-filmed and he got removed I I would
love to see the original Game of Thrones
pilot which was apparently a disaster
but it had George Martin wearing a
ridiculous hat so I would like to see it
rhaenys says something about stranger
terrain era uh well the stranger is the
god of death in the religion of the
faith of the seven and I think that
rhinis was saying that like you know I
know death because I've lost my both of
my children I think that's what she was
saying uh Madison says that when amond
and Demon stare each other down aemond
shifts his gaze away after trying to
hold the stair
does he have a problem staring people
down yeah maybe aemond is a little
intimidated by Daemon so something that
I noticed that I liked was that was that
Daemon couldn't meet viserys's eyes when
he when he saw how sick he was like this
scene where rhaenyra and Daemon come in
um I I loved how Daemon was so
uncomfortable seeing his brother so
unwell like look at look at where
daemon's looking like he's avoiding
looking at viserys's face rhaenyra looks
at viserys's face but Daemon is like
unable to face how unwell his brother is
like it hurts him so much like look at
him he's just looking off to the side
like Daemon just can't handle it like he
glances and then he looks away again
like he can't deal with his brother
being like this which I thought was
really wonderful acting I I thought you
know showing daemon's pain you know the
man that he admires and loves so much
being so unwell is uh so painful for him
thanks for the Super Chat from otaku who
says the amond beat Cole who beat Daemon
therefore in the power rankings amond
must be better than Daemon
uh is Cole using a mace a regular thing
uh Kristen Cole is best with his Morning
Star
you know he's better with a Morning Star
than with the sword
um
sovitsa got the impression that viserys
had a poppy-induced dragon dream of Jon
and Dany I I don't think that the milk
of the poppy would give you prophetic
dreams I think the milk of the poppy
would give you a dreamless sleep like
they talk about it dulling you you know
uh Patrick says will we see a Dragon
Battle by the end of the season well I
don't want to spoil anything but uh like
a fortune cookie I'll say that uh odds
are in your favor thanks for the Super
Chat from Jaden who says would you say A
Song of Ice and Fire is your favorite
fantasy to cover
uh yeah I I think so I think that
there's a lot of like unique things
about A Song of Ice and Fire that make
it great for like making videos about
like because there is you know there's
all these shows that you can compare to
all the books and there's so many
different sort of angles on the books
with like the main series and the
prequels and the world book and Fire and
Blood and Like A Song of Ice and Fire is
so rich with ambiguity Mysteries like
unresolved issues I mean the fact that A
Song of Ice and Fire is unfinished is a
Eternal source of frustration but it's
also an eternal source of discussion you
know the fact that the books aren't over
mean that we can still talk about what
might happen you know
um so yeah I think a song of us and fire
you know it's it's got a lot going for
it
yeah it's almost like there's a reason
we've made more than a hundred old shift
x videos about the Song of Ice and Fire
I think that's true if you include the
the show videos
uh Lewis is heartbroken that viserys
loves Emma Harold says that the viscerra
scenes were beautiful what a performance
from Paddy considine yeah I mean yeah
yeah we've got to applaud viserys for
his performance I I think that viserys
really did bring a lot to this show and
it's going to be sad without him I I
mean and you know the original actors
for Alexander marinara as well Emily and
Millie I think were amazing um so it's
sad to see those actors go but uh I'm
enjoying the performances from some of
the new actors like you know amond and
Helena and um there's much more to look
forward to uh Mal doing says bastards in
this world supposedly are untrustworthy
and I'm enjoying that rhaenyra's
bastards are mostly decent people but uh
Alison's trueborn children are not yeah
yeah I mean that's one of the points in
the books as well is that you know
people who have prejudice against them
like bastards
um are not are not all evil you know
some bastards are dig kids like Ramsay
but you know people are not all the same
and not everyone who is in a social
group especially a [ __ ] made-up
social group like bastards
um you know some are good some are bad
not all the same
uh Samo why did you say that name
battler sent are you saying that Alison
was like Batman I really enjoyed uh
vemon saying bastards like he was like
I'm gonna say the truth and I'm gonna
say it loud you guys are
bastards it was fantastic uh chungus
we've already discussed Helena I think
she's talking about spies in the walls
and future events Jess says how does
viserys even know about the prophecy the
knowledge was passed down Targaryen is
but joharis was technically never Heir
so who taught him yeah I mean that is
one of the weirdnesses of the whole
situation of
um of this whole prophecy being passed
down situation
um
because like visiris says that oh you
know aegon and his heirs have passed
down the White Walker Dream from from
King to air for Generations but it's
like well hang on maegor stole the
throne from anise's son and so then
maegor was killed and then jahiris was
like the fourth-born child of anes and
he took it despite you know him having
an elder brother who may have been dead
at that point but then Joe Harris was
you know he considered aemon his Heir
but then it was Baylon and then no one
considered viserys so it is extremely
unclear like how the information about
aegon's dream like made it through this
whole like Chinese Whispers telephone
game from aegon to viserys and there's
even more shenanigans that go on between
viserys and the later Kings so I think
the message may have been garbled
um along the way and yeah it is it's
very questionable how exactly uh the the
dream got passed down through the aegon
and maegor era especially so yeah there
are plenty of open questions there it's
almost a retcon like it's almost like a
show thing that doesn't necessarily fit
perfectly with the books but um
but yeah uh Rodrigo says will we get a
face reveal from alt shift X well face
reveals you know everyone loves a face
reveal right everyone I mean it isn't uh
you know like the Dream YouTube channel
is perpetually enhanced by the face
reveal right no one's ever disappointed
by a face reveal anyway you don't want
to see my eye patch it's a real doozy
thanks for the Super Chat from Molina
who says amon's crystal eye yeah what's
under the eye patch what what does he
keep in there snacks maybe maybe he's
got maybe he's got a snack in his eye
patch in his eye socket Jeffrey says at
the end between viserys and Allison
viserys says it's you and then the look
on her face changes Alison knows he's
talking about Rainier no I think when
viseris says it's you viserys thinks
that he's talking to rhaenyra and he's
saying you rhaenyra are the prince that
was promised I think that's what viserys
meant when he said it's you and I think
that Alison in the moment really did
believe that viserys was talking to her
about her son aegon but like yeah I
think it's very much like motivated
reasoning
uh thanks for the Super Chat from motaz
who says does rhaenyra actually not know
the truth about lane or I think that
rhaenyra does know because like Daemon
was saying to rhaenyra like set lane or
free like Daemon was saying to Rainier
let's let Lena live so I think Rainier
doesn't know Lena was alive uh Natalie
says why is incest more accepted in this
series than in Game of Thrones I think
the answer for that is that the
targaryens are at the peak of their
power and they have dragons and they can
do what they want like George Martin has
said that when you have dragons you
don't have to listen to the church when
they say you can't do incest
um that they're in a position of power
and so their their rituals have to be
more accepted because no one can no one
can question them at this point
but then later on in Game of Thrones
when the targaryens fell down their
Customs fell with them and you know the
targaryens no longer had dragons later
on so they weren't able to do what they
want as much
uh Jess says do you think amond and
Helena are having an affair
yeah that would be a parallel to Nares
and um aim on the Dragon Knight
um I mean aemond did say like I would do
my duty and I would marry Helena if you
didn't aegon so yeah there is some
groundwork there I don't think there's
any evidence for it but I think that's a
interesting Theory I mean like aemond is
not
aemond is not a great guy
he doesn't show a lot of uh sensitivity
or reflection
that we've seen I mean maybe Helena is
like the one person who aemond is nice
to I'm sure I I can see people shipping
that but um yeah I I guess you know
there could be a tender side to aim on
that he shows to his sister Helena yeah
I mean look that would be a very
Targaryen thing to do that would not be
unprecedented
thanks for the Super Chat from Jaden who
says the actor who plays aemond needs to
play bloodraven oh what if amond is
blood Raven with time travel I don't
know tambili says viserys showing up
like Jonah Hex at a dinner party some of
his cheek is missing rational says both
sides have good reason to fear what the
other might do paranoia is the Real
Enemy and and you know the system is the
enemy the political system that that you
know puts one bloodline at the top of
the others and forces conflict I think
that's part of it too
um we're going to answer as many super
chats as we can real quick and then
we're going to conclude the live stream
uh because it's been almost three hours
my goodness flement Brax says what's the
deal with Targaryen death dreams aemon
had similar parallels with viserys yeah
I mean Amon maester aemon had some uh
insight about prophecy towards the end
of his life in the Game of Thrones books
um he sort of realized that Daenerys was
the prince that was promised or he
thought so at the end of his life uh
mazaria's motive she has spies what game
is she playing yeah I don't know is she
going for revenge against Daemon is she
just going for her own empowerment is
she working with Otto still is she going
against Laris lots of lots of things uh
Alyssa says do you think this season
ends with a certain event at Storm's end
I don't know we'll have to wait and see
Nathalie says what about viserys calling
rhaenyra his only child yeah I mean like
you know Rainier was viserys's only
child at the time that he named Rainier
heir to the throne so it wasn't
necessarily you know disinheriting
Allison's children but uh yeah I mean I
think that I think that viserys loves
Ray Nero more than he loves Alison
partly because you know Rainier is
Emma's daughter and you know parents say
that they love all their children
equally but sometimes that's not true
uh DC says the three eggs that demon
pulled were were for Daenerys in Game of
Thrones yeah I mean if they want to make
more connections between House of the
dragon and the original Game of Thrones
show then making those three dragon eggs
the three dragon eggs the Daenerys takes
uh in Game of Thrones that that would be
cool I mean there are theories already
about like
the eggs that Alyssa farman takes from
Dragonstone in Fire and Blood like maybe
they are the eggs that uh Daenerys gets
because they go to a pentoshi uh spice
Monger which is you know pentos is where
illyrio has the dragon eggs in Game of
Thrones so I think that it's probably
those eggs Alyssa's eggs that end up
being daenerys's but you know there's
good
there's there's plenty of ambiguity
thanks Kevin thanks Shannon Lowell says
I don't like the inclusion of Prophecy
um just a plot device to spark the war
yeah I I have mixed feelings about them
talking about the prophecy since this
particular story is not really about the
prophecy but there are a few ways that
they could tie it in later that might be
interesting
Fernando says is there any lesson to
learn that that someone really ought to
disinfect the Iron Throne yeah Chuck a
bit of Clorox on those Rusty ass blades
uh because yeah I mean at least part of
viserys's sickness came from cutting
himself on the throne all the time like
he had those sores on his back which you
know maybe they were like Fresh Cuts
from the back of the throne so yeah you
gotta sit cautiously on that thing
Olivia says that rhaenys could have been
told safely yeah maybe Rainier should
have told rhaenys that her son Lena was
alive
um but it's a dangerous truth because
you know if Lenor is alive then Rainier
is married to Daemon is arguably
illegitimate and then uh rhaenyra's
children with Daemon are arguably
illegitimate like yeah that's a new
angle because in the books lane or does
seem to be dead but since Leno is alive
in the show you could argue that Rainier
is children with Daemon aegon and
viserys are also bastards Rainier is
children with harwinter bastards and
arguably her children with Dame on a
bastards so it's bastards all the way
down which has huge political
implications so my God it's even more
complicated
thanks for the Super Chat from Anastasia
who says viserys referred to rhaenyra as
my only child in this episode didn't he
yeah
yeah well is she what she was the only
child when he made her hair Juan says do
you think the moon tea was fake and the
maid is with the Spy the bastard child
is going to be used for some kind of
claim on the throne I I think that the
moon tea was real moon tea but I think
that we should definitely keep an eye on
any potential Royal bastards like the
reason like part of the reason why
Allison was so uh insistent on
preventing this maid from giving birth
to any bastard children of aegon is
because you don't want bastard claimants
to the throne it complicates things uh
cannibal has not appeared yet House of
playing with my heart Eric says was the
king murdered it looked like he was
bleeding I don't think he was bleeding I
think he was crying on his deathbed
there
um crying for his dead wife Emma I think
Isaac says despite being at the weakest
point from leprosy viserys exudes
Authority just by entering a room yeah I
mean I think that everyone's shocked
when he walks into the room because they
know how sick he is and like he has not
done this he has not walked or sat on
the throne in ages and so that that
alone is like oh my God because like
everyone was so comfortable in their
little schemes you know like vemond and
Otto were working together and they were
like we're gonna we're gonna Ally we're
gonna disinherit Luke we're going to
disinherit Rainier but then viserys
walks in and says no like I'm still King
I'm still in charge and I'm still in
support of rhaenyra
uh Brendan says my love yeah I think
viserys was talking about Emma Lowell
says doesn't Brian have a wheelchair at
the end of Game of Thrones so did
technology advance
well Brandon Game of Thrones did talk
about uh wheelchair history and he did
talk about a Martel who had a wheelchair
uh maybe wheelchairs have not been
invented yet you know maybe that's too
advanced I feel like I feel like they
probably should have invented
wheelchairs by now like I mean what
technology do you need to make a
wheelchair you need a wheel and you need
chairs and we've seen that they do have
both wheels and chairs
but who knows Carlos says medieval
dynasties are scary this could result in
so many people dead in modern times all
these teenagers will just get a spanking
and and it'd be done yeah combining uh
family drama and sexuality with politics
is a dangerous mix and it's a good thing
that modern day politics is perfectly
rational and peaceful and everyone gets
along all the time and feelings are not
involved and everyone just is Kumbaya
kirowic says kiwi ironic says mazaria's
next car who cut her throat does mazaria
have a neck scar
I don't think I saw that what was the
next scar
mazaria oh yeah okay I think I'd see
what you're saying it does look like
mazaria
has a line on her throat
uh that's interesting
um I don't know what mazaria's next car
is I don't recall mazaria
I mean maybe maybe she's always had that
and maybe that's like when she was a
slave maybe she was like abused or like
a victim of violence as a slave maybe
she always had that next guy
um I don't remember seeing it previously
though
it's a little bit mysterious did she
always have that next guy she's got a
high collar there
um she's got her hair over her neck most
of the time
she well yeah she's sort of covering her
neck previously so I mean maybe she's
always had the neck scar yeah she's
always covering her neck maybe they're
going to talk about that maybe that's a
thing
yeah interesting necklace some people
are saying is it a necklace
I I think that's on her skin I don't
think that's a necklace
uh are you all right people in the chat
are saying it's a necklace all right
maybe we're crazy uh kiwi asks about
dayron I think we might see him later
George says did the sea snake really die
uh well no they're not saying the sea
snake is dead they're just saying the
snake is wounded and might die
G1 says Rainier doesn't seem aware of
Leno's survival I think she is aware
because Daemon said let's set Lane all
three
um I think she just didn't tell rhaenys
uh Zachary says join the schwifty Army
to reap incredible rewards yeah well you
know alt shift X the YouTube channel
lock shift X is dangerously close to 100
000 subscribers and I do worry that if
uh people subscribe to alt shift X there
uh there might be more alt shift x
videos and that's the last thing the
world needs where's says aegon is gonna
drink himself to death yeah well I mean
he's in a delicate political situation
and being drunk all the time is probably
not going to help him make good
decisions uh Ina says how are you
feeling about young eye patch I think
that everyone is a fan of amond at this
point
OB says that Alison was on the bad side
of viserys's face yeah we've answered
most of this stuff
um aegon the first Crown yeah there was
a different crown on the preview sea
smoke I think is still around sorry
we've got to wrap this up because we've
been talking for too long Virginia says
is Jace a strong yeah like you could
speculate that joserus might actually be
the son of Kristen and rhaenyra maybe
Rainier didn't drink that Moon tea don't
know I that would be a big twist to add
but yeah I don't know it would be cool I
don't think it's true Patrick says do
you think that viserys was seeing Jon
Snow at that moment yeah I mean maybe
there was a bit of Prophecy dream
business going on in viserys's last
moments I I think I think he was Sami
Lucid though like I think he thought he
was talking to Rainier and I think he
was saying Rainier is the prince that
was promised which is just pure
Targaryen uh uh ego I think they all
want to think that they or their child
is the bloody Prince that was promised
like viserys
Praxis says thank you for these videos
and live streams it's become the Sunday
ritual thank you thank you so much Bax
William says viserys climbing the throne
was emotional I agree Austin says that
rhaenyra has matured since the beginning
she really has she really has like
Rainier was like an impetuous teenager
and now she is a lot more serious about
her responsibilities
um Allison was kind of always serious
about her responsibilities I think
Alison has become a little bit more
Sinister in her sort of manipulations on
her determination so yeah and Daemon I
think has mellowed out as well so yeah I
mean the whole time skip thing is a
tricky thing to handle but I think that
they um
are doing a good job with it uh solchi
papa says that Kristen Cole hasn't aged
yeah it I wish that they made Christian
Cole age I mean they could just put a
little bit of gray in his hair or like
grow grow out a salt and pepper beard or
something uh I agree that it's silly
that Kristen hasn't aged Cosmic says
that Azor ahai will come from the north
I think he said the winter will come
from the north and I agree that Vermont
is sympathetic Jacob says that amond and
daemon's yeah they look similar yeah I
mean oh what if Daemon lost an eye what
if and then like he had an eye thatch
wouldn't that be cool the eyepatch
Brothers Matt says that the greens seem
more evil but Alison is genuinely upset
about the conflict the government and
culture are the real problems yeah I
agree I think that they have a very bad
system that contributes to these uh
conflicts and I think that you know
Alison gets angry at rhaenyra when she
should probably get she probably should
be more angry at the whole monarchical
system itself
uh symmetry in A Song of Ice and Fire
ice and fire Rainier and Baylor Varys
and larus I mean if we want to get
numerological I mean the there's there's
twos in everything
um nature nature loves symmetry everyone
has two eyes everyone's got two arms
unless you're viserys Kaplan says when
Daemon walked to the throne I'd never
wanted to hear the word so bad I love
you brother yeah it seemed like Daemon
and viserys might actually say something
to each other and I wonder if Daemon
might you know later regret not having
told his brother he loved him in the end
that I think I think the impact of
viserys's death is going to be huge on
Daemon
username says why is murder in the red
keep so normalized yeah bloody Joffrey
lawnmuth and vamon valerion just [ __ ]
murdered on the floor I I think that you
know when when your demon Targaryen the
Rogue Prince you can get away with it I
think Kristen getting away with Joffrey
longmeth was a bit more ridiculous uh
sobate says Jace looks like Kristen yeah
well I think that the hair color between
Jace and Luke is different like like
Jason Luke do look different and yeah I
agree Jason's hair color does look a bit
more like Kristen's whereas Luke's looks
a bit more like Harwin so you know maybe
you could take that as evidence that
Jace might secretly be Kristen's son not
harwin's
thanks for the Super Chat from Andrew
who says I feel bad for viserys I want
to see him happy Lenny says viserys's
reaction to his family's moment of
Happiness was agonizing yeah there was
so much pathos with viserys and Daemon
OSU says it was very appropriate having
Alison on on the decaying side of
viserys's face Williams says if viserys
ordered jacaris to marry both Baylor and
Elena thus legalizing polygamy and
uniting the black and green lines that
would be hilarious but I think that you
know it wouldn't solve everything to
just marry everyone to everyone else
because you know people might have
favorite spouses I mean it's a bit like
when aegon the Conqueror married both
rhaenys and vicenia but then rhaenys's
child Anis was an enemy of asenya's
child maegor you know like marrying
everybody to everybody does not
necessarily end all rivalries kilmi says
who ordered the roast Pig for aemond I
wonder if Luke might have actually
specifically requested the roast Pig for
aemond or maybe it was just a
coincidence like Luke does have this
sort of like sneaky Snicker so maybe he
was behind it he's he's such a little
prankster Lukey such a little prankster
might just start a war Josh says this
whole thing is a good warning warning
against naming everyone aegon yeah yeah
if the names weren't all the same Alison
might not have been confused about all
the different aegons in the end
talked about Helena we talked about that
Flawless says no more in extreme pain
talking about well like Robert lyanna
feebot says I haven't even watched the
episode but I'm equally excited for your
live streams thank you feebot glad you
enjoy okay
we are going to have a super quick
glance at the on the next episode
preview and then we're going to end this
live stream and then we're going to
start working on the explained video uh
which will be the proper edited scripted
video so make sure you press like And
subscribe you might also like to
subscribe to the podcast feeds there's a
podcast feed that has these live streams
on it so you can listen on Spotify or
whatever you can even buy an ALT shift X
t-shirt if you'd like or an ALT shift X
badge you could put a not shift X badge
on an ALT shift X t-shirt I think that
would look great you also can uh press
like And subscribe and now we're going
to look at the preview
all right here's the next episode so if
you do not want to see the on the next
episode preview trailer You may wish to
avert your gaze
um Joanna says when will the explained
video be uploaded uh it'll be around
Friday or Saturday or Sunday one of
those days it'll be done as it'll be
done when it's done there's a lot of
work goes on goes into these videos and
it takes time but uh I'll try and get it
to you all as soon as we can uh we see
the throne looking dark and ominous who
will sit the throne after viserys's
death is obviously the big question uh
we have a meeting among the greens
deciding what to do after the death of
viserys uh he told me he wished for
aegon to be king oh Alison that's not
true that's AFib
viserys did not say Alison's son aegon
should be king vasera said that
reindeera is the prince that was
promised according to aegon's dream
Alison chose to hear what she wanted to
hear that's I think that's pretty pretty
damning on Alison
I'd like to see the context of this but
I think this is pretty damning for
Alison to be supporting aegon right now
uh thanks uh and then I said that
automatically and then there's a
commotion I guess the common people I
mean I would I would have liked to have
seen more from the common people because
the common people are relevant so I'm
glad we're seeing what the common people
think of all this who will they support
I mean rhaenyra was once called the
Realms Delight well they support
rhaenyro will they support whatever the
greens do let's find out
people are being made to swear and kneel
who were they being made to swear to I
wonder hey well it'll be to aegon the
greens are supporting aegon that's
what's going on here
um and none can know who you are or what
you seek who is that there's like a
bearded man
that Otto is talking to he is Otto
working with mazaria is this some like
secret secret Shady agent of mazaria or
is that Lara Strong's agent maybe Lara
Strong's person I think that Otto might
be like sending messages out to other
Lords and kingdoms trying to Rally
support but behind aegon but yeah what
is this secret mission
very curious oh is that the King's Guard
oh is that Eric or Eric yeah I guess
that's Eric or Eric and Otto was saying
you gotta lock everything down gotta
lock up rhaenys because since rhaenys is
sympathetic to the blacks you've got to
lock up rainey's so that she doesn't go
out and support Rainier
uh Talia the handmaiden is being locked
up so I guess I guess mazaria is not
working with Otto I guess mazaria is um
you know we know that Talia is working
with mazaria so I guess
um
Otto knows that and doesn't want Talia
to tattle and they ask what to do about
rhaenyra who was on Dragonstone while
all this is going on
uh someone's jumping over some rocks
that looks like a good time larys has
found out something
uh and it's about a blonde haired kid so
that is probably a bastard son of aegon
Alison's son and that's what Alison was
trying to prevent but it's happened
there's a bastard out there so will
Alison have this bastard child killed
like Cersei killed Joffrey it's killed
Robert's bastards
who knows or maybe that'll be a relevant
character later on uh Kristen pulls out
a sword and points it at Harold westling
oh God I really hope that Kristen
doesn't kill Harold westerling Harold
wessling is such a good guy but would
Harold wesseling allow the greens to do
what they're about to do oh boy Kristen
is is such a [ __ ] loose unit there is
little that he won't do
um Talk of treason
looks like uh the beesberry is opposing
the greens uh Power grab I hope that
doesn't end badly for the beesberry
we got some uh dragons of cloth where
we're talking Elena said earlier about
the dragons of cloth and the dragons of
thread uh so these might be the dragons
of cloth that shifa saw so is that like
someone throw an egg on around what's
going on there uh people filing into the
dragon pit for the coronation of aegon
that'll be fun I'm sure that'll go great
all of Otto's plans and schemes are
culminating we're getting to the
business end we're getting to the pointy
end now shit's getting real so uh my God
thank you for joining in this live
stream
uh I don't want to spend too much time
on the on the previous stuff because
there's plenty to talk about in the uh
current episode so uh we're gonna make
the video about episode eight just just
two more episodes left after right nine
and ten so uh my God it's uh it's been
fun
uh please like And subscribe and uh
comment below what kinds of questions
and topics you want included in the
explained video
and uh thank you everybody for the super
chats I apologize for any super chats
that I may have missed did as many as I
could it's been a long live stream and
uh we'll see you next time
thanks guys cheers
[Music]